oh you can't
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
what's up everybody i am thomas
dobasiola welcome back to the dope as
usual podcast we are here to talk about
life accomplishments drugs problems and
everything in between and i know i say
that [ __ ] differently every [ __ ] time
i'm sorry
so for everyone on the road please be
safe please if you're on your if this is
monday morning and you're listening
it's monday i know it's the shittiest
day of the week you got five more days
but you'll get it once you get over that
wednesday hump thursday ain't [ __ ]
and it used to be tgi friday but you
know
what wait do they still have tgf friday
morning hell no they don't have
they don't huh okay yeah never mind so
i'm sorry we're starting that [ __ ] over
there on mondays
there we go monday is the podcast so
that's your new friday
even though it doesn't help the next two
days you gotta go to work so
for like i said if you're in the car
thank you for listening thank you for
giving us some of your day
thank you for giving us the opportunity
to hype you up before you go into shitty
work i'm sorry
but um if you're at home chilling by
yourself or you just smoke a weed
hey what's up now you have someone to
hang out with if you're chilling to hang
out with your homies which we hear all
the [ __ ] time
hell yeah i'm happy that you guys come
here to watch me and marty like
like i used to watch the simpsons like
waiting just wait you know it's it's
[ __ ] monday that's that's the [ __ ] i
love dude i [ __ ] love it thank you
guys so much
that was the whole vibe we were trying
to create yuck in the podcast that was
the whole
hyped the [ __ ] like i got weed i got
something to drink no one's home let's
[ __ ] chill that's the vibe i want to
give you guys i want you guys to be
excited
you're coming to hang out with your
homie every monday that's
pretty much what we're doing okay guys
since we're there and we're doing it
again
10 minute nice guy clock all right we're
here
so let's uh let's start talking a little
bit guys um
it's the end of may all right this is
gonna come out obviously next week but
it's the end of may
that means if you guys haven't been
watching the news i haven't been
but i just see these things on the
internet apparently i don't know if you
saw it marty
june first they're disclosing what they
know about aliens which sounds
[ __ ] stupid that's more like
i sell this i sell packs to this guy for
ten thousand dollars
but he doesn't know i get him for a
thousand dollars but you know june 1st
i'm going to let them know
you know we get them for six like
they're not going to tell us what they
really get it but
not your message it's not coming it's
what they're going to let you go
hey you dumb [ __ ] that's what
you're allowed to talk about this is
what you can hear now like
[ __ ] i feel like they've diluted it
so much now it's like so normal to go on
worldstar
government confirms new ufo confirms
like
now you're talking about you're almost
like after the pandemic and everything
like you really gotta come
you gotta come full blown independence
day mars attacks for us to give a [ __ ]
but then again but then again i hope
that doesn't come to that
of course i don't want to be fist
fighting no [ __ ] aliens they're going
what is this pain thing like oh damn i
lost
i already lost we've seen it and mars
attacks we've seen it i'm the president
i'm dead
we've seen independence day i'm [ __ ]
randy quaid those are my favorite aliens
the mars attacks
aliens yeah that's when i found out tom
jones is not american
he had an english accent i was a kid and
go the guy that sings the crooner music
is
not a accent it blew my mind when i
realized
um christian bale is not american and
he's over here taking batman and
terminated like
yo you came and took that american
[ __ ] saga real but then again
arnold schwarzenegger was an american
but you knew it yeah
but
he didn't surprise you with it exactly
like when i was a kid and i when i heard
that i watched my first led zeppelin
interview i said
they're english i was shocked and when i
found out pink floyd was from england
like
what yeah it's just worse with an actor
though because they tricked me
they're good at it um the dude from uh
sons jax from sons
sons of anarchy the dude that [ __ ]
boggled my mind
okay you ready real quick story i know
somebody that knows him personally right
and we're just sitting there smoking
weed and i look out the camera
because there's cameras there because
they're [ __ ] drug dealers well no it
was at a dispensary they're legal drug
dealers okay
so i look at the screen and go is that
is that jackson sons of anarchy walking
in and he goes oh yeah i'm a bro
and then he gets up and go really
that dude from and i was i was it was
the last episode of sons that came out
weeks before
like it just ended i just stopped
watching it it was over
and then he walks in and i'm like huh
so this is why i bring this up he spoke
and i went
oh wait the [ __ ] did you just say
did you just have an accent i wasn't
aware because he was in a
undeclared that show in the 90s and he
was the english kid but i thought it was
just
acting i had no idea the guy that's
playing some [ __ ] hard ass gangbanger
from lodi
is from england or wherever he's from
that they're so good at dumbing down
their own accents to sound like me
yeah if you fool us the thing that i
always got upset like
these english dudes are just trying to
sound
stupid they smell just like me [ __ ] all
they do is make their elegance go away
oh hello hello what's up dude it's like
turning their
their english is like nice cursive and
ours is kind of just like chicken
scratching
ours is tagging yeah yeah and they're
over here
with ink pens and [ __ ] with a feather
anyway he came in and i went why the
[ __ ] was dressed like he
i mean i've been in many prisons i
visited a lot of people
he was dressed like someone that just
got to prison like before they get their
[ __ ] and they're still in their
sweatsuits
he had a gray sweater crew neck with a
white shirt underneath coming out a gray
gray sweats and air force ones with a
slick hair i think when i say crocs or
something
no this [ __ ] was dressed like he
was on the yard anywhere in west
hollywood
that's why i went is that text dressed
like
jax from jail why did we talk about this
i don't know oh uh independence day
aliens okay aliens all right i'm
the big the black dude he's a badass
he's the [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] badass he was running
people over in the nfl for 20 years and
then he became an actor
like oj oj was trying to take the jim
brown route and then he went
let me cut this bitch's head off i was a
kid when the oj [ __ ] came out
all i remember is the juice my grandma
goes the juice is in trouble like
who's that chocolate buffalo [ __ ] gun
oh he was from buffalo
i mean i forgot i
[Laughter]
hey all i know is i've seen the pictures
when i was a kid
i'm pretty pretty sure he did that you
can be a strong [ __ ] to cut
somebody up like that
you got to be yeah i don't think we're
breaking anything
i know we're not breaking any news at
all but that man's an athlete
pretty sure he did that one unless he
paid four dudes his psychotic twitter
rants really let me know he's a [ __ ]
psycho
after he got out i don't follow oh yeah
you might want to tune
into those he's just uh i honestly i
don't know what the [ __ ] i'm speaking
about but i've seen some twitter clips
of
twitter world and then he starts ranting
about like
uh you know like how he put out that
book like if i would have killed her he
just he does
inappropriately he put out a book called
like if i would have did it i need i
need to start paying attention because i
didn't know that was real this sounds
like a family guy episode man
yeah it just does not sound real he put
out a book called
the way i would have did it though yeah
look it up please
oj simpson book how to stiff arm
i did it it's called i did it
if i did it they what it did they put it
hella big in the middle
yo [ __ ] it you know what he's getting
his money back he's book sales i'm a
[ __ ]
cover art designer and i still don't see
the if i'd always
i did it in big red ink here so where's
the if that's [ __ ] up they really try
to sell that
that's what you call clickbait guys yeah
that's what you call clickbait all right
yeah that's what you do when you're
getting ready to go to jail you're
[ __ ] stealing your own [ __ ] back when
you go i was
in college when that came out you know
if you guys didn't know o.j simpson went
back to prison for stealing his own
memorabilia from a guy that stole it
but he had him at gunpoint so he did
aggravated robbery yeah
that'll do it you know what's crazy is
i might i would do the same [ __ ]
thing if somebody owes me money i'm like
i'm gonna go kick your [ __ ] door and
take something
not to talk about certain things but
what we just talked about the other day
like
do they not realize i know where you
live [ __ ]
we won't go oh we're at the 10-minute
nice guy yeah okay we're good all right
so let's get into it so here we go
the other day some [ __ ] happened i'm
like that's my motherf that's that's
our money like
i know where you live that's all we'll
leave it there like i told mario like
do they not understand i will
show up at your door with a letter
asking with a letter with an invoice
here here's an invoice i'm not fighting
you not because that and pull some oj
go back to go back i'll go to jail let's
see what did we learn here for what did
we learn
do not be like the juice all right don't
steal your own stuff and your own rights
to steal your own stuff
so we'll get past that let me let this
[ __ ] joint guys we're just
talking about a bunch of [ __ ] from like
1992
sorry that's per usual yeah that's true
here we go uh can you bring my
[ __ ] notes back up
so guys i have a it's not a new segment
but i wrote this down today right
this is called la [ __ ] i've seen a lot
of wild things merced
ellie's different la's like a
in video you know in video games where
you're level one crouch
is square and x x crouch or x x square
does a double jump
that's down behind yeah that's merced
you come to l.a and it's like
a crackhead oh [ __ ] how do you dodge the
crackheads so la's
the expert level so i want to tell you
guys
i'm going to tell you guys something
that happened the other day and i just i
told martin
earlier it just shows how desensitized i
am to this [ __ ] and how much i'm like
oh it's crazy i don't give a [ __ ]
what did you do so i was driving to
get food the other day and i wasn't
smoking a joint just like this
all right i wasn't
and rosie and i are in the car she's on
her phone i'm taking a right on
hollywood boulevard
as i take a ride on hollywood boulevard
i have to tell you this whole backstory
ready white woman maybe
no no white girl maybe 21 she's still a
girl
okay she's she's young with the mcm bag
designer bag guys are the little mcm
leather bags but like the little ones
the small
backpacks that girls wear i noticed it
right off the bat because
i knew i know the mcm back i see the bag
and i go oh
so this girl the way she was standing
caught my attention like she had her
hands on her head i go what the [ __ ]
i did not slow down i didn't pull over i
didn't break my neck i just
looked and went that's it because i'm
not trying to cause traffic like oh you
[ __ ]
it's a car accident keep driving stop
causing traffic all right so
um as i'm coming up i see the cop lights
and i go oh [ __ ]
what'd this girl do because i can only
see the girl right because his car is
blocking when i take a right
this girl this regular white girl is
wearing yoga pants
you can't have a gun in yoga pants
without seeing it correct
yoga pants like a workout shirt with
like a cut off halfway
designer bag her hair in a bun i
remember remember guys
this is what i'm this is all i see and i
see her with her hands behind her head
like
put your [ __ ] hands behind your head
like in cops we're sure it wasn't a
movie being filmed
there was no movies there was no cameras
and one little mexican guy with a rag
and i'm gonna get into that as i come
around the corner i see her and as i get
around the car
i see she has her hands up but that's
what caught my attention like i said
there are two cops guns drawn screaming
at this girl
she has her hands above her head on the
back of her head
facing a dumpster with a bag on leggings
yoga pants remember it's nice she had a
gun
and they're screaming at her again on
her knee obviously because i can hear
screaming and she's screaming on one
knee
getting on the other knee and i'm like
rosie look
as i'm looking and then right behind the
cops
two steps behind the cops is this
mexican dude that look like he just got
done working like in the kitchen like
a white apron on but he's got a rag in
his hand and he's just doing this
hmm right behind the cops like not with
him
he was right behind him like staring at
the whole they didn't know he was there
they definitely did not know he was
there
he was feet behind him they have guns
out all right their guns are
pointing at this girl five feet away
so what did i think damn what the [ __ ]
did you do
that's all not like oh my god that poor
girl
damn [ __ ] what the [ __ ] did you do they
got both guns two young cops
guns out on this girl right in front of
a restaurant so you you automatically go
too
she must have had this coming she did
something what did happen you do
and not like i know we should be like no
help why
why you have your guns first off why do
you got your guns out why do you have
your guns out i feel like there should
be a step between the guns i mean i
understand that there's like
tasers and [ __ ] it's so much to point a
gun at somebody it's a young girl
yeah and i know i'm like i'm not being
i'm not
i guarantee she doesn't have an arrest
record by the way she looked like
she shops at target for wine that kind
of girl
you know i'm saying like pier one
exports kind of girl and she had
she had [ __ ] two guns at her and then
i continued and went
man that was crazy and i got my food
that was it so
completely desensitized i didn't go oh
my god i went
[ __ ] that [ __ ] too and i kept driving
that was la [ __ ] today
oh yesterday not done
some more la [ __ ] you ready marty you're
so desensitized i came in the other day
i'm like
there was a dude standing on the median
of the five
12 lanes six in either direction you're
like yeah he's [ __ ] tweaking out
he's [ __ ] tweeting i'm like how the
how did he get there and how is he gonna
get across the other side there is he's
gonna walk
all the way till night time yeah you're
like he's gonna close his eyes and walk
across and be fine
hit by a car he's going to flip in the
air and land like a cat and keep going
for some reason god likes to spare
tweakers he's like no
no no he's been shot 40 times it's fine
he's been stabbed
twice today he's good i'm telling you
like voodoo dolls
i'm starting to learn this tweaker math
on this show yeah
put it this way you know in video games
you're like creating a character
charisma 99
strength 99 tweakers have a [ __ ]
death wish
150 pain level one
you can't knock a tweaker out i almost
had to fight a crackhead well he was on
meth
i almost had to find a meth head in
frisco when i was helping rosie back
raising her family back in the car up
this
i'm so cautious with everything and this
guy snuck up on me
and he had a face full of boils and his
lips were all bloody
like he had been picking his face and he
had something in his hand it looked like
a little tiny like blade but he came up
to me what's up big
so i'm like get away from me i yelled
him get the [ __ ] away from me
i didn't want to fight him of course not
no i'm two feet from the car the guy
runs off the other way when i yell
and rosie gets out what's up are you
[ __ ] kidding me that guy won't stab
me right now but what
back the [ __ ] car up and i'll tell
you and i told like you guys didn't see
that man was gonna stab me right now
this is like three years ago
and i thought oh i really wish i was i
wish i had that pill from chappelle show
well
sorry about the aids here's the cure
here's the antidote remember like i got
that herpes when it gets to the triplets
you might want to take that i wish i had
that so i could punch this [ __ ]
tweaker in the face and not worry about
getting stds and [ __ ]
crazy blood diseases that's a real
problem yeah you can't fight a tweeter
don't play this with san francisco is it
frisco they have the most by far the
most aggressive homeless people of any
place i've ever been wild
they're not they're not only like here's
numbers this goes crazy yeah yeah
they're like took over downtown last
time i was there ruining the [ __ ]
trip down there when'd you go
it was probably like four years ago
still pop you go by mission street we
were right downtown i don't know where
the [ __ ] mission is
yeah we were walking around and they
were just slamming on windows and
breaking glass and [ __ ] just they
were like extra it was like just
[ __ ] extra i didn't expect it for how
expensive it is to get a goddamn room
there for 800 a night or whatever the
[ __ ] it was
yeah but the [ __ ] frisco man why do
you guys do that to people
i got a hotel it's like 200 and i was
broke at the time i'm like oh my god and
i went to park my car
75 parking yeah that devastated me that
took a while to get used to
it hurts man i went to san diego and
they're like oh 50 bucks to park for the
night i'm like
[ __ ] we didn't work that in i know
right it's like the resort fees in vegas
like great seventy dollars a night whoa
two hundred dollar resort fee resort fee
i'm not going to the pool
[ __ ] can you give me a discount if i
don't touch the water
seriously or what's real fun is when
they still do that [ __ ] but it's coveted
like everything's still closed in the
[ __ ] hotel
and my apartment i live in now was my
expensive because all the amenities
and i moved in march 14th yeah
yeah last year i was so [ __ ] i
haven't used the gym yet it's still
closed
[ __ ] dicks anyway on to the next
thing real quick guys
desensitized to [ __ ] i've seen a lot of
crackheads see a lot of meth had seen a
lot of full smoking drugs
this one made me happy you ready i was
on 7th street
coming up to hope street if you guys
know where i'm at i'm on 7th street
coming up to hope
um coming away from the east la
direction do you have a weed pipe
god damn right
you i would have rolled your choice man
[ __ ] sometimes i like to switch it up
what was that noise
oh [ __ ] was it your computer yeah yeah
okay
sorry guys it's not your phone it's not
your phone
marty's a technological person
[Laughter]
his phone's just going off here we go
let's see here when it's on [ __ ] see
here um
ready guys this one made me happy i'm on
7th street about to hit hope
all right grand and take a left to my
friend's apartment
i am stopped at the stoplight i see this
crackhead you know for some reason
crackheads can do everything in the
world
but follow stop walk do not go yet on
the street signs
they just walk across the street when
it's when people are coming
of course when once you hit the pookie
you no longer you jaywalk
that's it you just jaywalk in front of
people the second you hit a pokey pipe
it's over
anyway this guy was a crackhead so it
wasn't a pookie pit he had a crack he
had a crack pipe
i could see it in his hand he has a
crack pipe he's got a ladder he's just
[ __ ] with it
walking in front of traffic that is
coming so they have to stop
wait for him to do the slow zombie walk
right
he's a black dude he was maybe like 27
not all but he was gone gone gone
you know where the crackheads where
their pants are like shredded
somehow on the back like where they sit
they were like blanca
when blanca from [ __ ] street fighters
like pants were just like shredded like
a hulk
a pirate or something yeah it was all
[ __ ] shredded he had a belt on still
and they were still
following that kind of crackhead so he
was holding it and he had a lighter and
a crack pipe
so i hear the sirens go on and there's
an ambulance and a fire truck coming
from behind us so i'm already pulled
over on the left about to take it left
so i don't got to pull
over i'm right where i should be this
crack is almost across the street
as he sees the lights come on this full
woke up woke up and like
[ __ ] yeah this man walked in
front like he went back to the middle of
the street
walked to the middle of the street where
the ambulance was trying to get through
dead stopped started doing some like
weird thriller
shoulder shake and just started roasting
his [ __ ]
letting out clouds of crack smoke dude
he started roasting it hard like that
and started like dancing like he was
he was loving it it's like the tv show
that he was starring
was that fire truck and as that fire
truck got closer
he started like getting in its way so
they couldn't pass and as they did that
he just started doing that
roasting it wrote and then i took a left
as i did that and the thing is
guys i didn't go oh my god i went yeah
like get good good [ __ ] that's the best
day he had
in a long time yeah oh yeah for some
reason like he was winning the fire
truck just made him light
up and i looked i was like rosie look
look she dances dancing i go
oh crap pipe because i said like look
and he started rolling
all those lights he thought he was gonna
[ __ ] yeah he was in a party or
something like
i've smoked cracked only once me i think
maybe no
once i don't think that other [ __ ] was
correct i spoke crack one time for sure
it did not make me want to dance it
didn't make me like lights
i was just pissed and uncle john yeah
hey was that crap [ __ ]
it's probably different when you go into
it wanting to do it first
i guarantee you no crackhead wants to be
like that yeah well
ninety percent don't man i just watched
the video with dmx talking about the
first time he smoked crack it was
[ __ ] heartbreaking
oh it was on to the quality's podcast
and he was talking about he was like
14 and this like 30 year old dude that
he like
really looked up to that put him on a
music basically like made him small
crack
or offered it uh hit it in a blunt and
he hit it [ __ ]
yeah and like it ruined his life from
there he started crying and showed it
was [ __ ] horrible
that's [ __ ] horrible yeah that's not
fair you don't do that to people
and he was like dm matt you could see i
mean dmx was so raw he starts crying
like why would you do that to a kid
knowing what you're doing and [ __ ]
but i mean i i have no contact for that
i don't know something that powerful
that takes
[ __ ] when i talk about getting laced
with that chris you know how many
comments have fools
telling their story about getting laced
i bet that shit's trash i got laced with
[ __ ] embalm well
sherm i got laced with ash i haven't
talked about it in here yet
one of the worst feelings i've ever had
in my life i didn't know if i was dying
i thought maybe like my brain was
shutting off
because i know people that have dosed
people with acid and that's [ __ ]
because how you gonna be just hanging
out and then go
oh my god i'm having a stroke my whole
brain's misfiring i'm seeing colors
like that's scary as [ __ ] yeah no you
don't [ __ ] with that
it's not funny there's a big thing
because it's just comedy because irish
severe
uh oh dos bert or some [ __ ] funny
but don't do it when they have their
kids there or when they have [ __ ]
like heart problems and [ __ ] oh i didn't
know that yeah i wouldn't do that at all
what are you doing with acid mdma or
some [ __ ] or acid
sick if it was mda i know i i feel like
that might be alright but if it was acid
that's not funny i mean
no drug you should never dose to anybody
yeah don't toast anybody
i mean a million subscribers where i
dosed all my friends but that was weed
all right they signed up for this life i
signed up for this when they were like
yeah i'll be your friend
yeah exactly it's good i'm gonna get got
they're gonna get me i already [ __ ]
know it but um
yeah i dosed my friends with the put a
couple ounces inside this
oil and then cooked a bunch of food
delicious it was like a catered buffet
it was bomb but after they ate i'm like
by the way
that was all medicated i planned this
for a while
it was fun anyway um no i did not see
the dmx thing that's sad
lazy simple crack is [ __ ] horrible i
saw this video on worldstar i wanted to
show you it just reminded me of it
because
what i've never heard the word pookie
out in
nature spooky like pookie like the meth
pipe and this
this is a combination of both let's see
if it plays through here it's our first
time trying to play a clip
this dude is from soft white underbelly
that you put me on to yeah
trying to rob this girl she's a robber
wait she's robbing him no and she turns
around and starts robbing him take that
[ __ ] shirt
broke his foot you broke his [ __ ] that's
why you what my [ __ ]
i was trying to follow back up [ __ ]
back up back up
she had a gun right by her side but yeah
yeah put the bike down
anyway she's about to she's about to
make him strip and that
hold on
[Music]
yo she is [ __ ] robbing him and making
him strip right there took a cds too
could you imagine you're going to rob
somebody and then this happens and
you're on worldstar good
[ __ ] that dude that's messed up you know
rob some girl
uh somewhere in there he said no no it's
just my pokey no you dropped my poking
is that what he said yeah
damn people's hitting meth like that
yeah he was
man [ __ ]
awesome anyway soft white underbelly
yola put me onto that [ __ ] on youtube it
is [ __ ]
disturbing ruthless brutal
you think you got a bad that's just
brutal dude a soft white underbelly
shout out to that
whoever's doing it he actually just
wrote in on that
no that's just a shout out from nature
this guy goes and pays a homeless people
or drug addicts in la
and interviews him he just sits on skid
row though with a tripod
yeah love it love that because you're
getting
the world of what these guys are doing
there's a couple people on there i'm
like yo how do we get ahold of these
people to help this guy
because some of those guys are still
there it's not glamorous there's nothing
glamorous about these interviews it's
bad dude
it's bad especially the there's some
people that are just
addicted to random the guy that's
addicted to acid
oh my [ __ ] god his brain is [ __ ]
gone he's sitting there he's looped he's
looped
imagine getting stuck in a bad trip he's
in it all the time you could tell
because he keeps telling the same story
and loops it like it never happened like
10 seconds tom from uh
50 first dates hi i'm tom that's him but
every like four minutes
it was it was bad dude it made me feel
horrible it
kind of like hurt my face i know i i
love and i've i
love interviews and i love
cinematography the way they do it but
it's too dark
the dude that was like the dude's like
my wife's got brain cancer and we're
homeless out here and uh all these gang
bangers moved in and they started raping
her now she's pregnant by the gang
bangers and they're basically like
extorting me and
like bro you're like [ __ ] 25 what the
[ __ ] oh
god oh it's so dark i know this [ __ ]
just goes on like
dude software that's different on the
west coast to watch man
oh god yeah yeah
okay you know i was talking about a
crackhead dancing and having fun but
software underbelly is way different
yeah shout out to them for putting in
that work
seriously when you as a videographer is
an
unrewarding [ __ ] oh man you're putting
their whole life on the line
nothing fun about doing that at all i
was not even enjoyable the stories
they're all sad
every [ __ ] one of them the hooker
ones are [ __ ] fantastic
dude and i don't say that word often
they're great because some of them like
no
i just make money like this and they're
completely competent and capable and do
regular [ __ ] and have lives it's like
wait
you're not just going getting crackheads
you're getting hookers that are just
addicted to drugs hookers that are just
want to make money hookers that do crazy
high-end escorts
hookers that live in the homeless camps
though
it's the [ __ ] he's drawing out of these
people is crazy dude
yeah or he gets john's dudes that goes
and looks for hookers
he interviews them like it's to get in
the mind of some of these people
wait are you stupid i think you're just
not people that have aspirations of
they're just active you just
hold them off the street yeah he just
got him real quick like yo you want me
30 bucks
yeah yeah let me interview you you talk
about your childhood yep
the guy that got you see the woman the
guy got shotgunned whole [ __ ] head's
gone and he's just so happy about life
still yeah
he was doing nothing wrong this is like
that's when it's like dan do you just
have a bad card
you just got a horrible hand in life for
a shot in the [ __ ] face has no
eyeballs tongues hanging out
still talking about like positive things
that that'll make you feel like a piece
of [ __ ]
oh my god i was sitting at a bus stop
somebody shot me in the [ __ ] head
like damn dude that's so sad
she liked that happens so much um
on something else all right okay [ __ ]
where are we at what time are we at
right now
where's the time marty we're at 31 31
cool let's get into this
remember guys uh the segment what's good
this is our segment called what's good
i'm just putting you guys on game of
[ __ ] that i like
marty likes cool deeds that people are
doing depends on what
uh direction we're going that day but
i think there's times when you when you
see an artist
or i get in a lot of comments what's
your playlist what's this uh what would
you listen to what you need to make a
place on spotify and make it open to the
public
guys i haven't seen you if you know if
you follow me for a long time
i really really love
like gangbanging drug rap i love it
depending on who's saying it like one of
my favorite rappers ever is the jacka if
you don't know who the jacka is from the
bay he died
he died a couple years ago if you don't
know who the jacket is look jack up
there's gangster rappers and there's
gang bangers
that rap and then there's gangster
rappers you know what i'm saying like
rappers that just happen to be [ __ ]
gangbanging ass fools
poets that are active and then there's
gangsters that are like yo let's let's
rap
make money that's cool too but when
there's like fools that are just
talented and by the way this is the
element in the environment they grew up
in
you guys know what i'm you guys know
exactly what i'm saying there's certain
people that are just so
[ __ ] good with their words like
biggie smalls was just a drug dealing
[ __ ] and just happened to start
rapping young
then look he only put out what one album
two
still one of the best rappers of all
time there's people that make an impact
that
didn't have much time here you know what
i'm saying that's crazy when you
consider tupac was like 24.
he's like 23 25 years old young crazy
kids man little kids killing it
forever making an impact forever of life
they will there will never
not be a cult following for them forever
of all time
and it's very odd to say that because
we're all lucky enough to get like 80
something years here
right so in 25
30 years this shit's going to be ancient
music
yeah i mean it already is think about it
now
when i was the 80s glam music just
left when i was growing up and it was
all you know
mainstream rap [ __ ] that i was exposed
to and you know that kind of stuff
but 20 years before that it was all
classic rock on the radio mm-hmm
you know so what is it now it's all wrap
where's the rock station
i haven't heard a rock station so
[ __ ] long where's his biggest rock
band now
can you name a big rock band listen i'm
not the one to ask oh you're right
you're right you're right you're right
i'm very [ __ ] sorry
the last big rock band system of a dog
no was a rock band that was popular was
like some nickelback [ __ ]
[ __ ] like that and i'm like i mean no no
no
no hate now you guys will i don't like
your music but other people
do they were huge what was the last huge
rock band
i don't know that didn't come out 10
years ago and still big i'm talking
about someone new like
where's the red hot chili peppers of
2020's yeah there's no bands there's not
a little bit of bananas
it's all gone so i'm saying um i
completely got up topic
completely i went into this talking
about your love for [ __ ] gangbanging
i know and then i went the other way
let's circle back there's people that
make a [ __ ] impact what the second
you hear me go oh
cause i've told you how many rappers
having my like i called it called it
five years ago i said it [ __ ] five
years ago
i heard this man and i went oh oh he's
gonna be popping i know you haven't
heard him yet
because you you're you're like stuck in
your five rappers you listen to
so remember when i tell you there's
certain rappers that are new that are so
dumb tight that you you can't deny it
you might want to type this in all right
maxo cream i don't i know i know
the majority of you guys know exactly
who this man is what is it
maxo m-a-x-o cream i think cream with a
k though
dude yeah the cream of the k that man
right there
i'm calling it now i think he's putting
out music
in by 2030 he'll be one of the
dopest rappers alive right dan that is a
long
[ __ ] projection i know but you got to
remember nobody thought snoop dogg would
be here forever he's [ __ ] 30 years
deep
but that [ __ ] 10 12 year mark he was
like
that's snoop it's not snoop doggy dog
anymore yeah that's snoop your worldwide
done you're [ __ ] solid you're
yeah that guy watch okay
bet i bet i [ __ ] love this fool's
music so damn much it's
it's so good dude you're gonna really
it's gonna resonate heavy
it's good i like how you do that i
really appreciate that about you how you
like
you got a eye for like deep hip hop [ __ ]
like that yeah i mean
there's of course if you have 15 songs
two of them are mainstream and kind of
like a little more like
i guess you would say malleable to the
you know for people to
understand like the pop yeah i guess
that used to be radio based that's what
i'm saying there's two radio hits per
hour but like that's what all rappers
have to do even kendrick lamar's whole
shit's all poet and poetry and he's got
that humble song
even though it's badass and it's steep
yeah it's still catchy yeah
you have to you have to be appealing to
the masses mass appeal
or it doesn't [ __ ] work yeah this man
right here oh
just wait on your way home i'm gonna
give you an album let's do it so
[ __ ] good the second i heard it went
oh okay i was 30 seconds in and go all
right this is this guy's a
bomb yeah um so that's my suggestion for
you and for everyone at home that likes
rap
that can't really go into this week on
spotify i change it every five [ __ ]
seconds i'm like oh
my god it just sounds like autographs
i've never done that it's
hard to listen to yeah i'm just not a
big fan of um
easy rap easy [ __ ] like big sean's cool
he's cool but his wraps are so easy and
they're easy to sing along to and that's
what's appealing yeah
but the [ __ ] that's easiest thing along
to isn't always the best
you know yeah i found over the years
that i'm looking for the same thing no
matter who it is
it's it's it's you really getting some
authentic [ __ ] off your
chest in combination with the the
collaboration with the producer
and it could be like my boy lucas from
austin i went down to austin walked into
a bar
and he was playing this kid's like 19.
his
as soon as i heard him i'm like oh god
i'm getting visuals of [ __ ] music
videos and [ __ ] like his energy
with the guitar he looks like a young
hendrix like i'm like
you know over when i was in austin those
couple months i [ __ ] dropped
every all the knowledge i could on that
kid just because his energy was that
it doesn't matter if it's rap it doesn't
matter if it's rock it doesn't matter if
it's
if somebody's tapping into that it's all
the same i feel like
yes dude and we talked about music on
the last podcast and
did you do you go through all the
comments i mean i don't know
how you go through a lot i tried to go
through a lot of them then you didn't
see it then
because there's a lot of people like so
what's marty's music name
where can we hear anything marty's ever
done what did marty do in music like you
know how many people ask that i go
i'll ask him on the podcast because i
can't i don't i don't know how to get a
hold of it you sent me a link like nine
months ago oh yeah yeah yeah because we
talked about a little bit
but you did music you you had you said
you had your [ __ ] on the
radio over there you moved out here to
do
you you talked about it briefly but you
moved out here because you're trying to
get a dr dre deal
right yeah so you're chilling with his
son for how long months hanging out
being friends you guys are doing your
thing you're still doing your music and
then you realize
oh this podcast thing is way more
direction of what i can do brand wise
because i never made a dollar doing
music i had spent it was all
like they say all money in no money yeah
it was and i was just getting to the
point that i needed a career
and i was just [ __ ] sick of dealing
with
how music is and i was just over it and
i was i had opportunity
with with the and i was given
opportunity that's what it was
i knew how rare it was so when i got it
even though it wasn't in
what i wanted i was ready for it and
just jumped on it and you didn't do the
g unit thing why there's a lot of
variables in that it was it was just
some music industry [ __ ]
you know basically but you're sitting
there but like it happened
when i was meeting with them and when i
went and met with him and all that [ __ ]
it was
on his it was he had hit his point and
was on the decline of g unit like
there wasn't a g i was in the manhattan
office it wasn't there
much longer after that oh like it wasn't
like at the pinnacle of
it was it was after that you know like
it wasn't bad no you want to be able to
be there after that yeah
and i mean everything that he did really
beyond like after that point that i met
him
it really wasn't nothing i'm glad that
he's he's kind of [ __ ] seems like a
psycho
even when i met him he was kind of doing
some psycho [ __ ] but uh
i mean it just wasn't meant to be you
know it was cool though
there's regular psycho [ __ ] and then the
[ __ ] that's like yeah that feels crazy
as [ __ ]
but you got to know him yeah you know
now that i know
now to me it was psycho [ __ ] then but it
really wasn't all it was
so like i took a train down to this is
funny i took a train down to i don't
think i ever told you this
down to manhattan the greyhound i was on
this type of [ __ ] i'd
straight up eight mile [ __ ] take a train
or greyhound down to manhattan
my manager at the time worked in the g
unit office i knew him through one of my
boys from lackawanna just a random
connection
uh my boy mooney his cousin was from
manhattan you know
and uh he was their like receptionist so
i started building a relationship with
him started getting this kind of like
deal with them
you know and then i went down there for
like a showcase i was staying at my
boy's cousin's family's house which was
crazy because they were like
muslim and they let me come and stay at
their house for the weekend and they
just showed me love drove me all around
new york city all [ __ ]
what do you mean some people that focal
rap uh in my experience i
listen of course they don't [ __ ] with
rap but they have no idea they don't
[ __ ] with strangers they don't [ __ ] with
white people
like like oh i can't [ __ ] human just
welcome these were complete strangers to
me
it was just cool that they were super
dedicated if you're willing to go stay
at some stranger's house
yeah yeah oh yeah you were sleeping on
whatever you were [ __ ] sleeping yeah
gotcha
so but that night i went up and i sat in
like i went in he was working i like sat
there you're saying he mean 50 cent well
50 was in the office next to me
my boy ace who was my manager at the
time was working he was a g-unit
receptionist yeah
so like i came and sat down and i hear
50 talking and he was like my idol he
was all
my boys idols at the time he was the
biggest out period
and especially the type of music that we
were doing and he was just it was funny
because he actually talks like you hear
him because he was like
yeah yeah man
i was like laughing they had all the
vitamin water and [ __ ] it was like right
when that happened
and i'm just sitting there i got my bags
i got pictures from this day i got like
did you have any kind of headphones on
no i don't know
if you did then you know what i imagine
sorry real quick i don't want to
i have to i imagine you looking like the
two white dudes
from boondocks
the one that charlie murphy plays and
samuel jackson plays the fools that are
[ __ ] shooting everybody if you guys
watch boone i feel like marty's those
guys that were
use uh ex-soldiers that are just oh yeah
[ __ ]
but you gotta imagine a white dude
dressed like a g-unit
played by charlie murphy yeah it's a
very crazy combination yeah i gotta
re-look that up yeah all right
sorry continue you're there you have the
bags from that day the picture
boom your boondocks go yeah so i'm just
sit i'm sitting there in his chair
there's the wall to his office
and then ace is like uh curtis you got a
call
like and then he like came out of his
office and
took the phone and like had a call on
the actual landline phone
oh damn yeah so i'm sitting i'm sitting
like so i'm looking at him now so you're
just sitting there waiting to hope to
get an
opportunity yeah later that night i had
a showcase in manhattan that ace was
going to take me to but i was hoping to
showcase me
showcase means you pay and you go and
perform with five other acts in front of
a panel and ours and you
may or may not get to do what i used to
do i used to drive back to new york
six eight hours each way to do [ __ ] like
that in the same day
oh wow just go down there stacks of cds
and [ __ ] and do these little like
showcases
so that's what i had one of those that
night gotcha
uh but i met him at the office and i was
obviously hoping to meet 50.
so you were just dedicated sitting there
waiting to go hey can i can i talk to
you in a minute oh this is my most
glorious story i ate [ __ ]
for a decade oh my god
so uh anyway he comes out with a phone
landline
he's like okay yeah nah oh oh
oh you didn't oh you didn't oh you got
that down but you didn't get this
oh you got oh you got and he starts
[ __ ] freaking out on the dude and
then literally
he's like all right and he starts
freaking out he slams the phone down and
he looks over at me like who's this
oh [ __ ] you got the worst of it
i'm just sitting there i got my bags i
got my
who's this homeless kid yeah basically
i'm just sitting i'm like
19 you know what i mean so i
like that's really just how it went you
look right over at me right after he
slammed the phone down
who's this yeah hoping you say something
stupid kick your ass out
i was a little [ __ ] because i should
have been like [ __ ] and just went in on
him like
looking back in retrospect that's that's
what i should have did
but it was more like what's up man just
slapped him up and like
sat back down and
then like i didn't know it but i was
sitting next to chris lighty at the time
who was like the biggest manager
in hip-hop period puffy's manager 50s
manager
he was like wheeling and dealing on the
phone and [ __ ] so then like a
photographer popped out of somewhere
and i got up 50 ended up sitting where i
sat and then like they did like a
makeshift little photo shoot right where
i was sitting
him and chris lady oh she's passed away
since then
so then i took like i had a little
manila envelope with my [ __ ]
press kit and i went in and gave it to
the president in a g unit
and like walked around the office and i
came back and sat back down and then we
went into the [ __ ]
uh showcase yeah but that was the i mean
that was the
only time i really met him oh man so the
retrospective should have been like
[ __ ]
yeah she just [ __ ] dropped she shoved
him in the chest and started wrapping
yeah yeah she just swooped his chain off
my like you'll get this back when you
can freeze
that dude oh [ __ ] yeah i had that was a
moment that that was a really big life
lesson for me because i realized like
take advantage of what you have if this
ever happens again
you gotta just [ __ ] go in
so that they gave you your press thing
and they went
okay cool you're another random [ __ ]
person trying to get into the music
we don't want you here basically cool
all right totally fine
but that made enough noise that the
ripple effect doing that made enough
noise because
this is like early myspace days so if
you go and do some [ __ ] like that
this was when even just getting on a
feature with somebody could make you a
star
yes it was different so there was a
there was a much bigger chasm
to being like a famous act it was like
there was only there was gatekeepers to
the [ __ ] there was only a chosen few
that made it it wasn't like
everybody's kind of famous a gray area
it was
you were on or you [ __ ] weren't and
when you weren't you were appal
you were planets away from where you
were trying to be
yeah like it wasn't like you had you on
youtube you'd like boom drop [ __ ] there
was nothing myspace was brand new so i
was mixtaping it i would go get 5 000
mixtapes from the city in my moz
or my [ __ ] escort station wagon and
drive it back
and and take all the cases and then take
all the cds and take all the inserts me
and my boys would back up 5 000 of them
and then out of the trunk with it
basically damn
yeah [ __ ] so did you ever put out full
albums
yeah i got like probably five
full-length cds oh [ __ ] for real
i didn't know that i just heard one song
well the one i sent you is called
california campaign so i went by stoic
s-t-o-i-c stoic s-t-o-i-c
stoic yeah like if you go to buffalo
everybody calls me like sto
everybody calls me stone oh wow
completely different yeah yeah
you know but um i publish some of the
music under drastic graphics because i
want to use it in some videos and [ __ ]
might as well trying to get verified on
instagram and [ __ ] [ __ ] got
all kinds of [ __ ] published out there yo
if there's anybody out there like the
[ __ ]
yo how many articles how many magazines
how many spots how many [ __ ]
super bowl commercials do you got to do
to get a [ __ ] verification
i mean come on what else do we gotta
[ __ ] do we're on spotify apple google
everything now that you're allowed to
get a verification
they told us [ __ ] off for our dope usual
instagram
hold on we never even applied for
promotion we never even applied to do
stuff and it just said at the top
i've never seen that before yeah it's
because you're affiliated with literally
like post we posted the picture of
deanna and then it was like by the way
you're not allowed to have retirement
you can't advertise
you're disabled like we never even asked
[ __ ] but as soon as they saw my
face they went
oh oh what can we shut them off for
before
before they even ask before they even
start getting a following what can we do
yeah i'm telling you dude ever since
it's something about me yeah there's
something about me that people don't
like
it's whatever it's all good but yeah but
the cd you're talking about is
california campaign so that was the last
cd i put out and it was like
when i knew i was going to move to
california so that was probably my
favorite one
nice but if you were to go back and
listen to like i love it because it's a
little timeline in my life
yeah like my first cd i put out was
called whatever it takes and you go back
there with some grimy [ __ ]
it's like it's a completely different
mind state i like like if my kids were
to go back and listen to it you can
hear me grow from 18 to 25.
being completely [ __ ] reckless to
being completely focused and then
california campaign i was on a [ __ ]
mission and then it happened
i recorded half the cd in a closet on
the east side of buffalo
my boy t literal gunshots coming through
the mic from outside
multiple times and i recorded half the
[ __ ] album
in this ski lodge in hollywood the dj
skisha the [ __ ] was happening as i was
doing it
so i had to go to california i did ten
days like living my dream out here
crazy ass story about how that all
happened but then i had to go back to
buffalo
i did a [ __ ] collections job and in
winter
and like oh that was that that was it
yeah that's all you needed to see was
like buy that next spring it was going
to be it yeah oh yeah
i was ready to put my life on the line
for that totally understand yeah
damn so that answers your question guys
for people that keep asking in the
comments there it is
s-t-o-i-c california campaign
yeah that's a pretty cool it's all
original music no mix tape [ __ ] what do
you mix tape like sampling
like it's all like i go in with
producers who play instruments and [ __ ]
oh oh [ __ ] yeah like like if you look at
griselda all the studios like the guru
doll studio in buffalo i love seeing
that [ __ ]
i love seeing those pictures out of gcr
and buffalo out of the studios because
those used to
i love seeing that success come out of
there now it's [ __ ] awesome that's
cool
yeah that's different for you yeah it's
completely different with all with the
success coming out of buffalo right now
[ __ ] just makes me happy every day
good
yeah what was he going to say god dude
sorry i just
i just [ __ ] my words up so bad i can't
even remember what i was going to talk
about right now
i just [ __ ] my words up i forgot hey
man that weed is strong
it's a true classic oh my god you got a
fresh batch
yes [ __ ] high damn sorry podcast here
we go
snap back in i was just i was literally
imagining snow
and you walking around with big ass
boots on
that sounds like marty with a big coat a
sideways [ __ ] fitted hat
yo you are the dudes from [ __ ]
boondocks man i'm telling you that's
what you are
oh my god all that was from that okay
maxo cream yeah go check out house of
crates yeah
so for some reason guys on the interview
with the drug dealer
episode i i cut it out of the youtube
clip all right wait is it in the audio
yeah
oh it's in the audio already
it's not live well
so i'm taking out the youtube version
okay um
i met geraldo rivera and i say greg
geraldo the comedian
and it makes an honest no [ __ ] sense
on why i mixed those names what do you
mean they both got geraldo in there i
mean it's pretty cool
rivera oh they're right there yeah okay
okay [ __ ] name anyway i [ __ ] that
up in the in the
dealer's audio and i realized like damn
why you hiding the weed marty he'll be
all right
you'll be all right just trying to save
the listeners here oh
is that why gotcha all right i'm already
smoking out of a wee pipe over there
here we go here we go guys uh on to my
next what's good
if you like rock music if you like
alternative rock music i guess you would
say
check out the violent femmes my mom put
me on to them when i was
born i don't know i was trying to think
of an age but let's just say my whole
life like i told you a lot of my music
comes from my mom
uh growing up and anything after 14 i
found
13 i found but go check them out guys um
violent femmes they're just a great
[ __ ] band i know they're like from
the 90s maybe the 80s
this is not like maxwell cream's new
these guys are old as [ __ ] and they're
[ __ ] awesome
so if you like any kind of rock music go
listen
it's bomb as [ __ ] it i find myself
listening to it
every week no matter what no matter what
news station i mean i always just
look at the violent fans for a minute i
don't know what it is about speeding
smashing in the car and listening to
this band is [ __ ] awesome dude
i know i probably should have said that
but [ __ ] it
all right so we got marty's uh rap
rap career story right here talked about
maxo cream violent femmes that
is going to conclude what's good that's
our segment of what's good and that is
um
the longest rant i ranted for
so [ __ ] long right now guys i try
i try every time we start let's just try
to keep this hour and a half it's not
gonna happen what do we have i guarantee
we're at like 51 what are we at
55. [ __ ] okay here we go sorry guys
we're trying to keep them tighter
because i'm out here rambling but here
we go marty i have a question for you do
all right how about this remember i said
i'm gonna start doing this in under four
minutes
for three to four minutes can you tell
me the story of the first fight you were
ever in
oh i like how you put the time bracket
on i'm gonna do it to myself too
because i i'm gonna try to like tighten
them up
and under one clips on our eclipse chair
yeah yeah
yeah yeah can you generate a nice clip
based around this angle
oh jasper uh here
first fight first fight first fight
where you went
and you got that adrenaline like oh [ __ ]
maybe you didn't punch somebody in the
face
but that first fight maybe it was a
[ __ ] tussle and [ __ ] like you guys
are slamming each other
you know what i mean like that first
like the first the first
fight i got into was me just getting
punched in the [ __ ] face when i was
like 11. that's fine
yeah did you retaliate yeah no i didn't
oh that's not a fight no because the kid
was like
probably 15 or 16. damn yeah it was i
didn't expect him to do it either it was
completely unexpected what happened we
were playing
we were playing football and uh he kept
all our he was like pushing or doing
some extra [ __ ] to my one friend
and i just like i was not expecting him
to [ __ ] blast me in the face
but he just i remember he like pushed
him in the back or something extra
and i just went up to him like stop
[ __ ] with my friend basically
not thinking that we're all friends and
the kid just blasted me in the face
just clean cross to the i had glasses on
two at the time
cut my [ __ ] eye all that [ __ ] so like
yeah i got up and told him he was a
piece of [ __ ] and [ __ ] took my ball
and went home
oh pissed yeah pissed
so so what was the first fight the first
fight where somebody actually tried to
swing at you too that was probably like
in high school
probably more like wrestling though yeah
what was it was the story
i remember i wrestled around pretty good
with the kid on my basketball team one
time i don't remember what it was over
but like i remember
there was like a little common waiting
room and he was sitting in there and i
went in there and just [ __ ] dove on
them all the [ __ ] tables and
chairs well [ __ ] went everywhere and
we wrestled around and [ __ ]
um
probably i mean there was really just
some little [ __ ] like that until i got a
little bit older
hey man that's fine yeah yeah i mean
it's just
i would say like in high school i got
into a couple little things like that
like i used to stick up for girls a lot
too
girls would wrap me up in their [ __ ]
like if a dude was [ __ ] with them
there's a couple times did you at least
get to bang those girls
i'm sure i did if i would really think
about it but the one i'm thinking about
in particular
no okay there was one girl who did it to
me kind of twice it was like my
girlfriend's friend
that's different you have to help that's
like yours yeah yeah yeah where i got
into an actual fight with the kid
one kid in school like in school like at
the lockers type [ __ ]
think about it i also got kind of pushed
into some [ __ ] lockers and got into a
little [ __ ] fight at a different
point in [ __ ] high school and how do
i think about it
but there was also a situation with that
same girl where i ended up [ __ ]
pulling a gun on one of these kids
no [ __ ] and that was uh you didn't shoot
him
[ __ ] no no but you had to pull a gun out
i pulled a gun to scare him
allegedly to get him away yeah well to
let him know to stop [ __ ] like they
were really
seriously harassing this girl yeah i get
it no i thought you meant something else
i was all [ __ ] retired about it
though i really was i was really
not even stupid for when i was about 18
or 19 as far as [ __ ] like that goes
just being real [ __ ] stupid and naive
but i but
probably by the time i was like 18 or 19
i feel like and i was so deep into music
i had so many boys that were [ __ ]
it wasn't like a gang but you knew you
were getting all of us for sure
yeah yeah you guys were that's how
tagging crews start yeah they turn into
gangs yes i gotcha that's how that's
rap groups become [ __ ] go to prison
as a gang man
because they're just hanging out and
like we're not a gang
but we all will shoot you yeah there was
there was a lot of that there's a lot of
situations even up until recently
there's probably been like 15 instances
where i really had to [ __ ] press
somebody to the point
but i'm not the type to even want to i
don't want to [ __ ] fight anybody i've
known since i was
young i didn't want to [ __ ] fight
anybody not only fighting because i
don't want to get i've seen people get
stomped the [ __ ] out
i've seen people go to jail yes i'm not
like i'm on a mission i'm not you gotta
you gotta
you have to basically do something to
like my wife or kids to make me snap
into that yeah i don't
my thing is i don't like
feeling like i'm mean to somebody like
when i got my first big fight when i was
a kid
as i'm hitting him and he started crying
like i started feeling so bad i stopped
like even though that kid's a piece of
[ __ ] [ __ ] and i want to kill him i'm
not gonna
the second i feel like oh he wants me to
stop he's hurt
he's scared of me now mm-hmm like then
you start feeling evil like yeah
but then you know you're going to jail
too that's no i'm talking about
as a kid like that's when i knew i don't
like fighting of course i mean like you
have to [ __ ] feel
evil some kids want to want to as soon
as they see somebody crying like yeah
[ __ ] you yeah yeah scott farkas of the
world yeah the weird
weirdo kid but but not even weirder kids
ufc fighters like i want to knock that
[ __ ]
and i'm going to start training i'm
gonna start training so i can kick you
in the mouth
that's different i don't like the i
don't like feeling
like i'm the cause of someone being
hella scared or yeah of course
that would make you a piece of [ __ ]
right right so that's why i don't like
fighting
yeah because and like i said unless you
do something
crazy i'm not gonna first time i ever
hit anyone in the face i was 25.
i think i talked i don't even talk about
this i punched some guy in the head
because i was always
so scared like oh if i hit somebody and
they die that's the thing like when you
walk around and you're bigger than
ninety-nine percent yeah i'm not even
taller or nothing but like you come in
contact with really strong yeah like you
don't want to
kill someone could you imagine going to
prison what'd you do
i didn't mean to hit the guy i didn't
mean to hurt him and now i'm in [ __ ]
prison with you
i i loosely told you a story about one
of these events
when like probably a couple weeks ago
where like
somebody did do some [ __ ] to april and i
really was on a mission to [ __ ] kill
this dude oh you talking about the
youtube yeah so yeah like
we won't talk about it we're talking
about who he is but i want to lead
everybody on
he's a huge youtuber
uh i forget where i was even going with
that but there was something
told me the whole story yeah stocked
this guy's house for maybe like maybe
like 10 11 days like
what yeah i was like waiting on the
ditch i was ready to kill this
it was horrible that was i hate that
that was a whole chapter in my life
where i was plotting on this [ __ ]
fool and then we ended up moving here
this was
crazy yeah i was calling up from him
before you stalk some man so he can
[ __ ] stop him to death
i felt like i had no choice that was the
point like i felt like
he did you were right i was totally on
the right i'm like [ __ ]
it's leave it kind of vague though i'm
i'm on a mission
first of all i'm on i'm i'm freakishly
on a mission just in general
with life so for you to take me off my
mission and now it's like i know i'm
gonna go to [ __ ] jail
[ __ ] i got a [ __ ] six-month-old
one-year-old whatever
time frame this was yeah but i'll tell
you yeah yeah that's the that's the
worst thing it's like man i'm doing so
good
and now i have to go to jail now i have
to divert my [ __ ] all this yeah it's
just
yeah like a bummer like oh my god it's
like when girls know they're gonna whoop
a girl's ass like
all right hold on [ __ ] and she's taking
her earrings off
be careful that girl yeah that's the
kind of level you're at
it was even worse cause the dude went to
jail they're like the people
it was a known thing what the [ __ ]
happened so it was like when he
oh everybody knows what he did
uh anyway we'll stay off it so much i
can see marley
we'll keep it at that we'll keep it at
that yeah but that sucks so that happens
i mean especially when you have a wife
or whatever especially when you're young
and you're in a shitty little town you
get put in these predicaments
you were so mad telling the story you
literally said
i vaguely told you no you told me in
clear detail what you did
and the [ __ ] i was in the ditch you told
me man
that was that was scary it was halloween
too we're like bro
a fake knife and a real
it's like how do you react doesn't
nobody teaches you how to deal with that
[ __ ]
that's why i always say dude i'm so
happy i grew up a nice kid
yeah because i would be a murdering
[ __ ] all these guys that get
caught merced you know how many gang mem
gang murders or merced when i was
growing up and they always got caught
and i always thought like we got caught
killing somebody on six on eighth street
on ninth street
how did you get caught no one had a ring
there was no [ __ ]
camera so you got to be kidding me you
got to be here reckless
um when i was like 22
my little brother i have i have multiple
bros my little brother mary told my dad
got married to a lady and she had a
bunch of she had three kids
so not the older one the middle one is
like i'm tight with like it's like
we grew up together more like it's my
brother martin and
i remember it's crazy your brothers you
got the same [ __ ] name
oh yeah i never think about i just say
martin martin and
uh his his two
friends this is sad bro it's very sad i
remember when this going on i was
thinking damn these young kids are
getting
murked so merc said there was a weird
time where like
16 maybe 15 to 20 year olds were getting
shot all the time there was a one summer
like up 12 kids got shot
like four parties got shot up but this
kid
uh he was like 20 and the other kid when
i was like 19 the other kids 16 they're
brothers
but somebody ran up on them right by the
bread store and merced
somebody ran up around their apartment
knocked on the door their dad answered
the [ __ ] guy shot their dad in the
chest
and [ __ ] the two brothers came out
the full murked both of these brothers
on the doorstep
dad lived killed both of these boys and
the mom runs out to find her whole
family shot up
on the porch like you you know what i'm
saying like
what the [ __ ] did you do what could be
worth all that nobody caught because
this 4k
mass the [ __ ] up ran he's only got kind
of one camera like by a jack-in-the-box
i think or
by the dmv they caught one camera of the
guy
but he ran off into the ghetto like
you're supposed to
but so many people get caught this all
came up i'm so glad i'm nice
because there's so many easy ways to
kill [ __ ] in the ghetto
but now it's harder because of rings
people got camera phones but
i remember hearing one of my boys
justify it like he was like
thinking out loud to himself like
knocking a [ __ ] off in the hood
like isn't the same as like a regular
person is what are you
saying oh that's [ __ ] that was the
gist of it he literally just say crazy
[ __ ] like that like
[ __ ] himself nothing if i could take
the life of a goldfish i could take the
life of a person
i remember like it's all life i was like
damn that is a dark way of thinking
about [ __ ]
bad i was just remembering though that
the dude last solo episode i was telling
you about that facilitated that whole
situation
i i punched him clean in the face prior
to that happening
that was like an overt me at like
looking to punch somebody in the face
oh that's how we started with let's get
off this murder [ __ ] back to the fight
your first fight
all right that was your first fight you
ready for my first fight it's not as
baller as yours your [ __ ] string of
punching people
um my first fight ever guys uh
my mom moved my dad to clovis which is
fresno basically
uh it's an hour away from her set so i
am for
beauty and the beast that just came out
right
and gaston when you're a little boy
gaston's rocked out
all the girls are on gaston he's eating
12 [ __ ] dozen eggs
full has trophies gaston's the man right
so first time i watched i'm like oh man
this guy's [ __ ]
i didn't pick up on the [ __ ] subtle
alpha guy [ __ ] because i'm [ __ ] four
years old i just thought like
you know this guy's [ __ ] bill she don't
like him he's tight
so me and my friend i i'm in clovis
i live acro i live you know we have a
house my dad and my mom my uncle abel we
all
and my uncle brian uncle abel's husband
well not anymore my uncle abel's
boyfriend at the time
michael bryant and we lived in they
lived in a room my mom and dad lived in
the room and me and my sister she lived
in a room
and it was a fat house it was a nice
house in clovis across the street was
this mexican kid
and i was friends with him you know why
because we were the same age and he was
alive i was alive and that's how you
become friends as kids it doesn't
[ __ ] matter
that's how you become friends so i saw
him like yo best friends
high five and we hung out it was like
weeks into me hanging out with this kid
we played dodge ball and like
football just play video games on sega
little kid [ __ ] in the 90s right
so one day i brought up beauty and the
beast because i remember we're sitting
indian style we're watching it
and he goes all my trope remember
gaston's like look at these trophies and
he shows the trophies and then my friend
looks at me oh
he's got trophies that we ah and that
was the first like bro moment i ever had
with a kid
i went no why and then we looked at each
other like
yeah and then by the end like oh he's
the bad guy [ __ ] this guy
anyway that's my friend right that's a
whole back story just to tell you
the kind of relationship i had with this
kid it wasn't very strong
we were just we were neighbors all right
so
one day we're over there i'm outside of
his house and his family's having like a
party
so there's a bunch of uncles and ants
you know mexican [ __ ] right we're all
mexican people
and um he has
cousins i'm like four or five may no
maybe four no
[ __ ] maybe three maybe three or four man
i'm a [ __ ] child i still had
training wheels so let's do that um i
walked
you know i was so it was so long ago you
could walk across the street your
parents don't have to walk you there and
make sure you're okay because my mom
didn't give a [ __ ] she opened the door
and i was back when the sun was going
down
that's pretty much how it worked right
anyway i'm with the kid we're all
playing like
kicking a soccer ball around my friend
gets close to me
this is where the fight starts sorry for
this whole backstory marty but i had to
do it
my friend looks at me all right he's got
his cousins one skinny tall cousin
tall but he's like seven or eight so
he's way [ __ ] older than us
right way older than us
i'm not in school yet that's how young i
am so whatever age you are before you're
in preschool
that's how young i am my friend leans
into me he's got one
two like three cousins and
my friend and just me my sister's not
there nothing i'm just with myself
and he leans into me and goes hey we're
going to beat you up now
marty what kind of evil [ __ ] evil [ __ ]
dude
i swear to god there's something about
me as a kid that people are attracted to
be
like to be sounds like jesus people are
[ __ ] ruthless to me i don't
understand your mind
the first time i ever got fully jumped i
was in second grade
doing nothing and shout out ignacio and
brian
and brandon they jumped me and i beat
the [ __ ] out of two kids and they both
cried and ever thinking what's wrong
with you guys you guys literally just
started sucking me up in the field
second grade or maybe third second or
third grade but
that [ __ ] is not normal i don't know
they started jumping me beat just
started sucking me in my [ __ ] ribs
and [ __ ]
and i just grabbed him both and slammed
him i was a [ __ ] fat kid well i
wasn't that fat but i was still pretty
big
and uh he cried he landed on his
shoulder anyway off topic
sorry guys damn my brain this weed's
good all right
so my friend leans in i'm back in clovis
he goes we're going to beat you up now
damn dude my brain needs to stop that's
some prisoner creepy [ __ ]
i went off tropics so [ __ ] bad right
now
yes it was some prisoner creepy [ __ ] i
went what do you mean
this is me this is me today i swear to
god dude i've been
this brain since i was since i can
remember how to talk
it's been the same logic like why
for what well then you're wrong since i
was a kid
no assess the situation and he goes and
i go
what do you mean he goes yeah me and my
cousins we're going to beat you up now
and i saw he was serious he was dead
[ __ ] serious okay so my first fight i
was like three or four
it reminds me of the kid from butterfly
effect ew
okay i get that right there right but he
was like
it's not like he was like [ __ ] you he
was like hyped
yeah that's what i'm saying that makes
it even creepier yeah
yes like that but the kids next door i
haven't even gotten to them the kids
next door the white kids
they were kind of like everyone had
grasp at them
like they had a dirt flan and they were
kind of like the broke kids
but we were all poor but it was still a
fat house to me all right it was it was
probably like a normal house but yeah to
me it was fat it wasn't an apartment
it was a big house and um
anyway i look at him and i go
what why and i was like but for what he
didn't say nothing he just backed up
and then this tall ass cousin came close
and i went oh my [ __ ] god
i've never gotten beat up but nobody but
my sister
so i don't know what to do
i'm hella scared my friend's looking
straight at me like
smiling almost and i'm looking at him
like
you're my friend what is happening
because all i know is i've never seen
[ __ ] over movies i've never seen
horrible
friend movies yet there's no paid in
full have not
hasn't came out yet all right i haven't
seen cameron do that [ __ ] to makai
pfeiffer i don't know what's happening
yet i love that reference
thank you for that yes so i'm like
but why and then i just [ __ ] like
almost started crying and i got so mad
and i kicked my friend in the dick so
violent
hard i pointed my toe up i remember his
friends
his cousins coming and i just and i went
my friend right in front of me he kicked
him in the dick i mean i felt my toes
stop
like i hit him [ __ ] hard i kicked him
with everything i possibly had
toes pointed up just where i knew like i
know where your dick is you're a kid
like me
i'm going to kick you right there and i
hit him so i probably really heard him
but i hit him so hard it hurt my feet i
hurt my toes
really bad he dropped to the ground
without the no yell just dropped and as
soon as he hit the ground like
like you know in jurassic park when
pterodactyls come out
like that kid screamed that blood curdle
[ __ ] on a delay
yeah like exactly
but his cousins just went backed up
immediately
i went like this and started running
backwards i had my hands up like
oh like a crab i had my hands up like
this
that's a good form yeah i found this
[ __ ] going on dude i was scared i was
scared like oh my god
they're gonna [ __ ] me up now but i just
remember thinking i'm gonna at least hit
you
once i was just more hurt that he'd like
i'm like wait what
why why i remember think but why like i
didn't get it yeah
no it's horrifying i backed up i checked
both ways i knew it i'm like check both
ways [ __ ] this is the day you
get hit by a car
you're like trying to run away from this
check that's how it happens yeah i went
uh-uh
ran across the street i look and his
cousins are all checking on him looking
at me
i run home and i'm screaming balling
crying
i run in the house i tell my mom like
scream i was [ __ ] screeching louder
than he was because i was so mad
and i'm crying and my mom like i can see
it on her face like oh my [ __ ] god
what happened because she's like
oh you're you're hurt what happened and
i told her like
i don't remember his name i told her
what happened he said you were gonna
beat you up now remember i'm a kid
and she's like trying to like so he's
gonna what like i'm crying
incoherent and she goes so he said he's
just gonna beat you up like yeah his
cousin said they were bigger
and then so i kicked him i had to and
then she's like no you're fine
you're that's fine you can hit him like
you're not in trouble
because i was in trouble yeah and then
[ __ ] two minutes later we get a
[ __ ] knock
a loud ass knock the loudest knock at
the door guys
and it's him
and his mom and his mom's mexican lady
but his mom
doesn't understand by
knocking on that door you open yourself
up to getting stomped out
like you're on your unwilling
participant you don't know what's
happening because with my if you say the
wrong thing to my mom
you opted them you signed a contract
verbal contract to get your ass what
because if my mom doesn't like what you
have to say after what i just told her
about your kid
the first thing i thought was oh my god
my mom's gonna [ __ ] you
up and i was fine with it i was mad the
kid's like four feet behind her and he
is
bawling still and he's holding his like
where his dick
should be i guess maybe i kicked that
[ __ ] off bro i swear to god
i hit him so hard it hurt my foot like i
said
he's holding his dick he's just like
he's trying to catch his breath still
this is all within like six minutes
right i kicked him ran across the street
telling my mom a couple minutes later
she
get a loud pounding that's why i went oh
hell no
oh [ __ ] and then the ladies
like has a tone but she should have
all she knows is your son hit my kid so
hard he's [ __ ] throwing up and crying
what the [ __ ] she has every right to be
but
she starts looking at my mom and i'm
looking right up i remember i'm on the
right side of my mom i'm looking up at
her like
oh no don't hurt her don't hit her
because i know my mom she's crazy
and this lady's nice i go over there i
watch [ __ ] meeting the bees we get
juice and [ __ ] she's a nice lady she's a
regular lady
so i don't want but she was loud she was
very loud and the kid's crying and i
remember looking at him like oh i'm
gonna
[ __ ] hit you again like i'm i was so
[ __ ] mad
and just like pissed off looking at like
i just wanted to like
go up to him like joe pesci [ __ ] like oh
yeah
go get yo who's funny now i just wanted
to like to grab him by the back of his
hair and just
hold it like i was pissed and then she's
like yelling at my mom
looking at me telling him exactly what
happened and my mom
is like taking it fine she goes are you
done thomas tell me what you told me
and i just started i was crying i'm like
him and his cousins
oh i said the whole [ __ ] thing and
the second i went
they said they were gonna beat me up she
like
obviously they've done this before they
had to have because the second we said
they said we're gonna beat you up now
like she went and looked at him
and i'm like oh hell yeah good [ __ ] she
believes us right off the bat
she's i'm [ __ ] sorry i'm sorry i'm
sorry she looked at me like i'm sorry
all right we're gonna leave and then she
grabbed her kid by the back of the neck
like
like people lions do cats like when
they're babies
or when cats lions do cats like lions of
their cubs and [ __ ] like they grabbed by
their neck
but this one looked violent she grabbed
him by his neck and they just started
walking off my mom closed the door
and then she my mom like kneeled down
like some [ __ ]
john elway [ __ ] like this is what's
gonna happen okay you don't hang out
with that kid anymore i don't give a
[ __ ] if he wants to be nice to you you
don't hang out with him don't even look
at him don't have him look at you don't
talk to him i don't care what you do
that's it he never looked at me again
and i played with the kids right next
door a lot
even though they were mean but i didn't
want to be [ __ ] just by myself i
remember you know what i'm saying
yeah and um that kid never looked at me
again
but i remember the first time i had that
adrenaline of
like it's all oh my god like you know
that adrenaline up your spine yeah it's
the first time i felt it well
it's even creepier when there nothing
nothing happened and it's just the kids
you're playing with
god man that's so much creepier there's
only been like two times in my life
where i got an altercation that
there was like any kind of force back
from me
everything peop i don't know what it is
man
people have just been [ __ ] dicks my
whole life and that's what made me start
talking like an [ __ ] because
everyone's always so [ __ ] mean to me
those kids next door uh quick quick
thing they were the white kids next door
they were mean and my sister was a dick
she let him be mean to me
and the other kids next door would hang
out so be like eight kids there and i'm
the youngest
and they were all the older kid with the
[ __ ] like mullet looking [ __ ] was
always
[ __ ] mean to me it's always dirty the
white kid
and he did some cartoon [ __ ] one time
there was a 20-foot tree
and he put a [ __ ] circle rope and put
it over the
tree so if i walked in a trap yes
but nice i know cartoons i was ready for
this [ __ ] i was ready because i went
over there everybody's like hey what's
up tommy oh
hell no hell no you guys are in a u-form
what's going on
like come over here just put your foot
in there go for what
i was kind of like playing like [ __ ]
i'm not gonna get dressed
up in this pile of leaves yeah exactly
i'm like what all right and i got close
to it just because i wanted to look up
and see who was holding the rope
and it was the kid with a mullet and
then i went you put my foot here and i
[ __ ] pulled the rope and the kid fell
off the tree he fell off the tree and he
didn't break anything
he fell off the tree and he did that
where kids start doing the
breath [ __ ] um his brother started
punching me and then that was it i
didn't go over there
jesus christ but i got him i made a boy
fall at least 10 feet
onto his shoulder it was good [ __ ]
you know what's up with these side
topics today i don't know this is oh
that means [ __ ] was over
[ __ ] about childhood the whole podcast
are just side topics
i know that's horrible it keeps
reminding me of that piece of [ __ ] kid
and butterfly effect that killed [ __ ]
rocket you remember that
yeah it's like your your life was full
of those pieces of [ __ ]
[ __ ] there was some piece of [ __ ] kids
man i knew a lot of them
but i think as soon as i was like old
enough to
pick somebody over my head i was over it
was done
you know i mean people still talk [ __ ]
but it didn't get to the point where
like people were physically doing things
mm-hmm yeah i don't know i never had
that i never had you're [ __ ] big
[ __ ]
that's what it is even if you're not big
you're tall
yeah people see me and go
kind of small huh go i benched uh double
your body weight so get the [ __ ] away
from me
uh yeah i'm only like five nine maybe on
a good [ __ ] day dude
i'm five nine on a day i stretch mm-hmm
so like
i am not my aunts both my aunts you guys
i got the [ __ ] danny devito jeans
my grandma grace is german and
portuguese
why don't you guys break this down ready
german and portuguese born and raised in
agapuko so she is mexican
everything about my grandma's mexican
she doesn't speak german or portuguese
she speaks spanish
from mexico and she's a brown haired
lady but she died of her blonde her
whole life
she's super light-skinned she's like
your color probably very very pale like
have we confirmed your grandmother's not
wrapped up in any sort of like
nazi behavior my grandma knows oh
about her parents and [ __ ] i'm just
saying there was a i watched a whole
documentary on germans going to like
portugal
they're like middle east or not the
middle east south america
oh her brother's got blue eyes i'm not
going to hold that against
about six four and up i'm not going to
hold that against him either all right
listen
i'm just saying i watch the documentary
don't be saying [ __ ] about my physical
features thomas i am not a nazi
oh you [ __ ] i did not get where
you were going with that until the end
no all right my grandma's brothers are
uh
trying to flex my history of skulls here
my history skills
nazis nazis i'm pretty sure they went to
other places
and then then the rap took over my
school that was it then i just started
rapping
when i was doing tests um no all my
grandma's brothers the pictures of them
they're all six four up they've got blue
eyes now
all of them are gray haired but they're
all like
all the badges and they're mexicans army
guys
it's pretty wild anyway but my grandpa
is a [ __ ]
mexican aztec from the jungle my grandpa
greg is from the [ __ ] jungle was born
and raised in
leaves bro i'm telling you you got to
clarify that people think you're talking
about like a
neighborhood or some [ __ ] my grandpa was
born in the jungle
not where training day took place no the
jungle jungle where he's
used to kill snakes and make boots
that's that's how he made money
you can only kill a snake with a stick
and he told me what kind of stick
i was a kid when he he killed a stick a
snake in front of me at my grandma's
house with a stick and he went
are you [ __ ] kidding did you really
kill him with a stick because you have
to smack their head certain snakes you
have to just crush their heads
my grandpa's a ruthless [ __ ]
anyway he told me how to
clean and uh dry tobacco all that [ __ ]
because he used to take the tobacco
plants dry and sell cigarettes
he was on his own at four we talked
about this josh wolfe so he's a crazy
[ __ ] anyway he's tiny as [ __ ]
my grandma's all her genes are giants
then on my my mom's side
my grandma was jewish uh white lady i
think she's polish and something
polish and i don't know but they're all
from they're all from massachusetts
my whole family's from over there and
they're all bawling
hard as [ __ ] my i have a whole side of
family from massachusetts
yeah my grandma dolores uh her last name
is walden
because my grandpa but before it was a
jewish last name i don't know what the
[ __ ] it is
my great-grandma my grandma dolores her
mom married a catholic they wrote her
off that's it
she married a catholic was my grandpa my
great-grandpa dude
was a carny a white dude he wore
overalls a lot
and there's one picture of him i've seen
with my grandpa tom the cool one the
mexican guy
and he's got a pompadour it's like 1960
something he's got a pompadour
even my uncle mickey they all have
rifles and my grandpa my great grandpa
has a big hat he has a straw and like
two teeth
right here and he's holding the straw
with it nice and he has
no shoes on there by a river and they're
all hunting rabbits
like wow that's where the [ __ ] it came
from holy [ __ ]
that is my great grandma my great
grandpa was white dude and my
great-grandma's a jewish lady
and she's from massachusetts i gotta i
gotta say massachusetts cherry something
cherry hill cherry wood cherry something
but they're all ballin they'll have
estates so somewhere out there
is my jewish white counterpart
and i'm not kidding it's [ __ ] crazy
because i guarantee if i get that name
and trace it back
some [ __ ] watching from
massachusetts is probably [ __ ]
related to me by blood
and that's crazy as [ __ ] because my
other side of the family shane's
marseilles bronze
well you said they were like country
whites right like yeah
um they my great grandpa was but like uh
my other whole side of the family i mean
i'm the dark guy
i'm the darkest one beside my sister
like we're the brown kids
but like my mexican side of family like
we're regular uh-huh
it's just it was different it was
different growing up going to one
grandma's house
crazy different other grandma's house
uncle jaime's and nables and [ __ ]
santiagos and all that
they're crazy they always just [ __ ] with
me because i don't speak english but
it's also like yo teach me
[ __ ] uh-huh yeah again again
again um but yeah i don't know how we
got off on the topic but we're
we're back here again on a [ __ ] rant
and um yeah that's the first fight
we'll cut that back there cut off a clip
back there that was the first fight okay
um i almost got into a fight with an old
man about a year ago
he this is funny and it was in the
height of my kickboxing
classes so i was doing like kickboxing
every day
and i was in the shower and like
oh we uh we had to park our truck in
front of his house
because like our we were moving some
[ __ ] out and like we just parked on the
street that's all it was we literally
just parked on the street instead of our
driveway it's public parking
yeah and he came over and and he pounded
on our door and started freaking out on
april who was like
seven months pregnant at the time that
the garbage truck didn't take his
garbage because we were parked in front
of his house
and he started like [ __ ] freaking out
on her
and then he went back and he's like
probably like he's like
definitely a foreign dude in some way
but like i mean he lived there
he's like an original owner so i'm up in
the shower april comes and gets me
out of the shower tells me what happened
and i go
i go across the street to this dude's
house who just came
and pressed a pregnant woman you know
full kickbox mode this dude hides behind
his wife his wife comes to the door
and i'm i'm furious
but even in the moment no one is when i
see the wife answer the door i start i
talk to her like a gentleman
yeah i'm like ma'am i think your husband
just came over and addressed my wife in
like some
kind of psychotic way or some [ __ ] and i
need to talk to your husband
the husband's sitting in the living room
like he's sitting down in a chair at the
table i can see him like deep in the
house
and he's like scared to come to the door
this
it's probably like a six-year-old man so
he's got his wife talking to me
and his wife starts going like he had a
stroke if you could just oh my god
if he could he says a lot of like crazy
stuff
she's like embarrassed for this dude now
you got a dude at your door
uh could you imagine being like some 60
year old dude
and then you you're sitting there
thinking now you got some dude half your
age
imagine that guy at 30 though
terrorizing the [ __ ] out of you yeah
yeah oh i know but even
so what was funny though is that he was
like go back to where you come from
i'm like [ __ ] i was born here what the
[ __ ] are you talking about i'm american
and then i started lying i'm like we own
all kinds of houses
because we rent here we are [ __ ]
white trash [ __ ] we own five houses you
don't know [ __ ] you're just talking [ __ ]
no yeah we didn't own anything we still
don't yeah you're just gonna [ __ ] on him
yeah
just trying to put him in his place yeah
[ __ ] i'm half your age we live on the
same street
i've across the street from here dig
yeah and by the way we're allowed to
park
on the street once in a while the
garbage truck will always yeah and what
was funny is
it was a [ __ ] holiday that's why
yeah oh did he apologize nope nope so uh
anyway i i ended it like [ __ ] if you
got a [ __ ] problem come talk to me
and i walked away
and then later that day like my mock
came over and then i helped her load up
her truck and [ __ ] and i saw him like
bringing his [ __ ] garbage cans in or
whatever
and i walked up to him i had never seen
this dude like before or after
and he's like i don't want any problems
i don't want any problems and i was like
listen i'm gonna talk to him like a
small boy i want to shake your hand
because of this misunderstanding we had
and i just need you to understand it's
not okay to do that i'm not gonna be
mean mugging you every time i [ __ ]
walk out of the house now
so we're on the same page shook his hand
and that was it he never came outside
again
i mean [ __ ] i would never we never
interacted again
yeah gotta hate that's how most my
confrontations go if i if you do some
[ __ ] to the point
where i gotta compress you i'm gonna
come full force [ __ ] press you and
just end life when that happens we end
up the person that they're in the wrong
if you get me to that point you're in
the [ __ ] wrong
yeah i've never pre i've never gotten
mad at somebody and i'm wrong
yeah unless i didn't realize it yet and
then i apologize
mm-hmm oh i've i've only been i'm mad at
somebody like that once and i [ __ ]
apologize the second i realized i was
wrong because
yeah you can't be wrong and watch [ __ ]
up that this happened to you because
it's normally people that
if you talk behind people's backs if you
[ __ ] people over on money
these are people that get [ __ ] up yes
all the time you know like
that you'll randomly see getting just
stomped out yes
but when you're not like that that's why
i feel like i don't you know i gotta
more good comes in bad yeah so that's
that's that's one thing to think about
some people have these instances
every day yeah because they do bad [ __ ]
yeah so we just get it once in a while
to go hey you're still
you're still good you're still gonna be
all right all right you're still nice
all right here's more good [ __ ] mm-hmm
you still get to work for yourself and
do you think
you do that like so i think that's what
it is it's testing to make sure you're
not going to freak out and be ungrateful
for the good [ __ ] that comes because i
get pissed yeah
all the time i go you know what i love
that can't do anything about it yeah
yesterday in traffic i was in
the worst driving went getting mad is
not
help mm-hmm and i just stopped yeah
really i know that's so hard to do
though
i'll be all worked up for [ __ ] weeks
over some [ __ ] that makes no difference
to anything
me too i'm trying my best to stop
because
yeah i'll i'll hyper focus on [ __ ]
that's the thing i really when something
happens
as soon as it happens i'm like [ __ ] now
this is on my mind for the next
it'll stay there for two hours yeah
right here it's just there front and
center it's not going nowhere thing
uh-huh hey man we're good nah after the
chopper came down with our last episode
and they didn't [ __ ] bust in here i
think
we're talking about some [ __ ] yeah i
know um yo
let me get on to something let me get
onto something real quick guys i have to
tell you
some [ __ ] happened the other day that
might have never happened before in my
life
okay i did a video
oh that's i put this at the beginning to
talk about it and then i thought about
the nice guy clock so
here we go i did a video that's coming
out
i'm not sure when it's coming out
because you're going vacation so it
might be coming out this week it might
be coming next we're not sure
but i did a video as a freeze pipe right
and i'll show you guys a new rig
and as i'm setting up i'm looking at
charlie and i'm like charlie
why don't i just like do a video about
smoking all this hash
and we'll just make it like a wee
challenge smoking video and he goes okay
what do you want to do
and i smoked two and a half grams of
rosin right rosin hedge
but i smoked that [ __ ] in like 35 40
minutes solid
just powering through it and i said you
know what let's do the last dab the last
dab i forgot
i was supposed to take some out because
it's supposed to be a 2 gram challenge
so i ended up doing 2.4 is 2.5 like a
dumbass
so my last dab i said you know i'm going
to scoop the rest of this jar so i did
like a 1.3 ish dab
which is a [ __ ] lot when it comes to
like just dabbing
right like taking one big big grab
graham dabs is hard
but you gotta remember this is hash
rosin the [ __ ] was
stupid expensive it's so [ __ ] strong
so anyway i take this dab i've done it
many times
videos over 15 minutes later this
doesn't happen to me often
you guys ready 15 minutes later i just
got the spins
violent i don't know what point you
facetimed me but you were [ __ ]
cross-eyed
really yes oh man oh no
it was bad it was bad it was at the
point where i just couldn't think it was
after the game now that i think about it
oh was it yeah okay so this is what
happened
i got the spin so hard i went to my
bathroom put my face against the cold
and i just sat there and was just doing
this spitting
in the toilet just waiting for the throw
up like because i didn't eat
because i don't like to eat before i
shoot dab video i mean weed videos
because
i don't want to feel all tired and
bloated like i'm you know what i mean i
don't want to feel like that while i'm
trying to talk the camera me like do
[ __ ]
but i didn't realize it was going to
turn into a challenge video so i should
have ate
right because i'm dabbing two [ __ ]
half grams eat something
and i only brought one bottle of water
and i forgot to get more because i
thought it was gonna be a regular video
so i didn't plan well so i'm sitting
here dehydrated
didn't eat and then i went oh my god i
got this beds i'm gonna go throw up no
so i went to the bathroom didn't throw
up dry heaved for 10 minutes
oh god huh phil hella sick dehydrated
and then when i walked i got
dizzy and i still got the sinus
infection oh yeah update
the headaches back for some stupid
[ __ ] god damn it and i'm going to a
specialist
next week because this is some [ __ ]
it's back
my headache hurts my head it's right
[ __ ] out and i had the headache going
on i felt dizzy i felt sick i came out
here and there was
nothing to drink at all
so i sat down and went oh my god i'm
sick
the big part about this is two hours
from that time
i was going my first dodger game and
then this has been planned for over a
month and a half
going to my first dodger game and now
i'm thinking can i go
i can i sit in a stadium like this i
don't want to sit in a stadium dry heavy
thousands of people
dude dope is yellow that's your
prime demo too downtown l.a i took all
my logos off my face
because i don't want no way to talk to
me because i didn't want to be like i
met thomas and he was kind of like
hey what's up thanks man yeah all right
bye because i didn't want to just hey
what's up
i felt spins like when you're gonna
throw up off drinking i felt sick as
[ __ ] and i realized it was like a tangy
dab and that taste was in my mouth i
don't like tangy taste so it's like
grossing you out puke because that's my
grossing me and it was it was
so high so fast because i roasted that
damn so i can make sure to do it all
and when i inhaled that [ __ ] [ __ ] me
up that first cloud like left a film on
my teeth and lips of hesh
so awesome it's not even bad i just had
nothing to take the taste away
i'd have food and i have water i had
nothing after a huge dab
and not eating and it was four four four
thirty and i had been up since
nine here at the warehouse
[Music]
yeah see where this is going i started
filming at 11 so
like it was five hours of me constantly
doing [ __ ] taking dams doing this up
close this that
so i was [ __ ] up and then so this is
what happens guys
i call rosie i facetime rosie and the
phone's just down i'm just talking to
her because i'm so [ __ ] up i can't
look at the phone
and i tell her the situation because i
can't drive my car i could not drive
from here to my house
i was that [ __ ] up i didn't want to
get in my car part of me is envious i
haven't been this high and so [ __ ] it
was not [ __ ] fun
at all i wish i could take it back right
then and there i i was doing that have
you gone
from like drunk style puking from weed
like where it's just i've only thrown up
once and that's because
i was so dry mouth and i'd have any
water while i was coughing i went
the coffin i'll get you that's what
happened to me once yeah but
so high off that that was the closest
that was the worst experience i ever had
of any kind of weed situation in my life
besides the edibles that day
where i was passing the [ __ ] out on that
baby that day
so so here we go i
um call rosie and i tell her i don't
care what it is can you please order me
food because i'm gonna throw the [ __ ] up
she goes okay i ordered you food 35
minutes oh no
35 minutes like this i tell charlie
cause he has to go on a hike with his
dad i'm like no back up
go don't worry about me i'm fine just
going are you sure i'll wait here are
you okay
like i'm good cause he's sitting there
like are you all right
i thought it collapsed along i tell you
that i forgot i was so high just
hyperventilating in my head
and i couldn't breathe right because the
dad was so big i'm like
we're talking about one single dab well
i mean i took four
or three point threes because you're
pretty pretty good dabs and then it took
like a 1.2
1.3 like a glob and i [ __ ] at what
point do you start wasting the dab or
does it always
just no matter what the challenge video
if i wasted five
grams i didn't waste five grams it's did
i get it done
[ __ ] yeah that's all like a little
trophy uh-huh yeah yeah that's all it's
for
yeah yeah um so i tell rosie because og
and mindy
og and his wife are gonna come to the
game with us like that was the whole
point
and they're meeting me at my house and i
tell them
yo can you guys come to the warehouse
i'm throwing i'm gonna throw a [ __ ] up
because we still have an hour supposed
to pre-game get drunk and uber there oh
god we're supposed and i can't get into
uber she's like don't just uber come on
like rosie i'm going to throw the [ __ ]
up in an uber
short of me sticking my head out the
window i'm throwing up i'm done
there's no way i couldn't even get up
that sounds horrible to lock the door
when charlie left
i left it unlocked just cracked i'm like
i can't even get up and puke on the way
there
like i was spinning all you want to do
is calm and go to sleep
i put my elbow down on the couch i try
to sleep like this
hard as i could i set my alarm for 10
minutes so i wouldn't miss them knocking
on the door
and they [ __ ] came uh rosie og and
they're all
[ __ ] with me oh geez of course oh
she's loving it
little dabs oh he's just recording me
like oh
no and i'm sitting there just doing this
he has a video of me i didn't know he
was recording my eyes are closed i have
a gatorade rosie brought
a water bottle and i'm just doing this
[ __ ] over here and he's recording me
zoomed in i'm like i opened my eyes and
saw like [ __ ]
i'm [ __ ] throwing up man that's gonna
be what's on the screens at dtpg
in there next time it's me dry heavy so
they're all pregame and smoking i didn't
hit no weed nothing
and i'm looking at rosie like i might
not go
i don't feel bad it turns out og had a
driver in his car so there was no uber
so i could at least
get in the car and not throw up in an
uber if i threw him in an uber and i
told him if i throw up
i'll pay for your your whole detail but
let's go so we finally went and i said
if i don't feel good by the time i get
there
uber i mean the driver you got is taking
my place and i'm sleeping in the car
because i can't do this i can't do this
you're a better man than me
i can't i can't i'm like all right let
me get in the car i'm open the window
let me try to get better by the time we
get there and i'm [ __ ] spinning and
by the way
i have a black plastic bag from the
[ __ ] liquor store tied around my
wrist
right there in case i threw up and i
took it all the way to dodger stadium
okay you're with it i've been being all
[ __ ] up i was so
[ __ ] up and violently like sad how
[ __ ] up i was
and i'm sitting there rosie i'm
apologizing to her like 40 times i'm so
sorry
i today was the film day and that was
supposed to be done in three but it took
so long
and then i just felt bad like i don't
want to ruin the [ __ ] night
so i'm sitting there and in the car i
went twice i went i put my face in the
bag because i thought it was that was it
and it didn't happen
and then about four minutes before the
stadium
i'm sitting there and it just went and
all my sickness went away
like somebody went all right he's lasted
long enough and they just turned it off
and i went what the [ __ ] i said i went
i feel okay and og's like
he makes the weirdest references and he
doesn't make like the reference where
you know what he's talking about but i
get it because i know what movies
he likes he goes all right [ __ ]
cameron
do you get it you should is that a
ferris bueller wow you got it
good job i went oh like cameron when he
just snaps back into it like he's fine
he goes yeah fool i'm like
yo you got to give me i wouldn't expect
og i respect that though he's all about
that [ __ ] when first time i ever met og
i walked into this
gang banging ass looking [ __ ]
uh somebody introduced me to him right
somebody introduced me to him and uh i
was i was showing him some wheat because
he wanted to buy like some weed to smoke
my friend was there and i had some
this i met him so long ago i was still
selling weed that's how long of no g
i knew him way before i moved here and
uh
and i walk in like oh hell i've seen
train day full
i don't want to be in this neighborhood
in east l.a like oh
hell no because i never move i've never
been here
but just like mercedes he still is like
merced but i didn't know anyway it's
nighttime i walk in like oh
this fool's garage is scary his cameras
and [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
and then i meet him and the cranberries
are playing you know the cranberries are
is this why that dog face thing was even
funnier
no you want to know why the dog faced
things is even funnier cranberry all
right
all right because og's break dancer name
was mr tick tock
and then the guy the tick-tock guy that
looks like o.g
that dances looks like o.g
and i have a video because oh gee like
four years ago for some reason he would
always call me
and he'd be drinking something different
every time you facetime
what's up man parallel universes what's
up man and he'd just be drinking
something different
i have a bunch of ocean spray ones of
him and then when it came out i go
why the same [ __ ] sweater he like
took his likeness or some [ __ ]
he looks like emoji so much i always
used to make fun of him when that guy
came before he got famous off the juice
i always went hey if we'll start dancing
tick-tock guy i always used to call him
that i'm like hey dog face stuff is look
he goes [ __ ] you [ __ ] dance like that
and then i found i'm like you used to be
a break dancer full
that's too much that's going to make my
[ __ ] head explode i made my and
i'll give you the picture after this or
maybe we'll find him you know i'll find
him in my phone and we can put it up
there
he why do we get off this topic so much
anyway we go to the dodger game guys
we're walking in i feel fine
and i go uh i'm still spinning so i
started i was spinning but i didn't feel
like
but i felt dizzy like where i'm like
rosie hold my hand i don't want to fall
down look like a [ __ ] idiot
we got there as the like first couple
pitches were getting thrown
so we walk in first time dollar stadium
easiest place to get into it was so
[ __ ] awesome i walked straight in and
got straight that was easy anyway
i go in i'm like nah [ __ ] i flipped my
logos
i'm like no i don't want to wear my
logos in my face and [ __ ] because if
fools come up to me and like that fool
wasn't even like
hyped to meet me or nothing because you
you know you talk about your push
through his face mask yeah because that
shit's [ __ ]
wrecked it's on your front center it's
right in your face i went oh [ __ ] that
i flipped it because i didn't want to
anybody that's a sad day when you got to
flip
i feel like i felt bad though because
i'm not representing her i'm always like
you know every time i go somewhere i'm
like your people yo i'm not saying like
everywhere i go but
you're ready smoking [ __ ]
everywhere and i'm always like yo i
follow you
thanks man because i want to we're
talking about it earlier it's like some
fight club [ __ ] like
yeah yeah like it's just yeah
good [ __ ] you watch it [ __ ] you thank
you
and it's it's i always like to be like
normal i'm a norm normally when i see
somebody they're hype like i'm hyped
because i'm like yo
[ __ ] yeah yeah sick but i wouldn't be
like oh thanks man
and walk away and like oh that fool's
wack and i want one person to get a bad
experience because then they're going to
think that's how it is all the time
and then they're going to feel different
about how they were supporting it no i
love how you care about this
of course [ __ ] yeah i don't want anybody
to feel like they got a shitty
experience
if they met me or some [ __ ] so i turned
inside i was like no
[ __ ] that i just felt so sick dude i
went to the bathroom i felt sick
i just it went away to where i wasn't
like violently scared i didn't have the
bag on when i walked in the stadium
but i had the bag the whole time around
my wrist in the car anyway
went to the game it was [ __ ] awesome
i am a giants fan
because i'm from [ __ ] up north i
don't really follow baseball
mm-hmm but if i had to pick a team as a
kid like oh giants i had barry bond [ __ ]
as a kid
you know my grandpa liked it so if i had
to pick a team i don't really follow it
rosie's a die-hard giants fan so we're
in dodger stadium where the gangster has
looking lg
and every time the dodgers are doing
something bad rosie's like yeah like
hey shut the [ __ ] up oh [ __ ] that's
right i've never been to a dodgers game
but i can imagine ruthless
it's ruthless over there don't be able
to go in there with any orange and black
all right i didn't see
one giant jersey the entire time i was
there
yeah i saw in rosie's story i was
killing her it's like yes it's like
going to a raider game
you can't wear the broncos jersey okay
like my thing i always say but
people always i told you about this
people i said you should do fear factor
stuff like with weed [ __ ]
god no i don't want to be scared i don't
like being scared and i made the
reference
it's like wearing a broncos jersey and
walking through oakland stadium like
do you want to be scared and on edge put
that giant
put that bronco jersey on and walk
through that [ __ ] oakland stadium
you're getting in a fight no matter what
they you couldn't tailgate candle you
guys remember this
you couldn't tailgate a candlestick
anymore cuz that guy got stabbed
horribly
dude the niner stadium was ruthless as
[ __ ]
it's just gang [ __ ] too you could wear
raiders or niners or cowboy [ __ ] merced
at school because those were all gangs
and merced yeah that's all gangster
bill burst told a really funny story
it's on youtube about going to a bills
game
bills is just drunk like die hard fans
in the snow
jumping off [ __ ] and tables and stuff
and like
he was wearing like a patriots hat and
they weren't even playing the paper
they were playing like a different team
but he was wearing his patriots hats
and then the bills i don't know if it's
like this in other stadiums but they
have troughs
in the bathroom like the dudes pee in a
trough okay
and he was peeing in the trough and a
dude walked up behind him pushed him
into the trough
he had i think so
something happened he told the whole
story on youtube but that [ __ ] was
[ __ ] hilarious to me
you can't be touching people just
because they don't like your team
that's crazy no you can't push bill
byrne into a piss trap anybody
yes yes exactly it was like every
generic white male
is pretty much bilber yeah generic white
male over 40.
yeah but yeah that's what happened to
the dodger game guys
and then that was it i walked out it was
great
it was fun uh og's driver pulled up as
we walked out of the parking lot
like [ __ ] some boss [ __ ] haven't it
was
got in was fine but um i fell asleep
immediately when i got home
and that's the first time i've ever been
nice well that now we know what it takes
it takes me merely throwing up
yeah you just gotta [ __ ] do five
grams worth of dabs and
me too i don't know what it was man i
think it was the flavor that really made
me feel like i was gonna throw up
yo guys i'm sorry i just went into ten
topics in the middle i gotta start
saying on topic
because sometimes i feel like when we
try to do clips for the clips channels
like yo
from 6 20 to 8 30 and then skip about 10
seconds
because he started talking about [ __ ]
all real monsters and then can you go
back into the [ __ ] fight story he was
talking about
that's what i do well i mean that's
actually a nice segue because we're
hiring right now actually at drastic
graphics
for a video editor help podcast and
that's a skill that we're looking for
you got to bust on these goddamn
marty you [ __ ] you slip that in
well right there
yes so where are we going to hit people
up at or where can people and hold on
we can't have people that are willing to
learn easy learners yeah
no we need people that are established
that can do this tomorrow we already
have
probably i put it up on my instagram we
probably have 20 pretty qualified people
that i already hit us
please fix your profession yeah if
you're if you're
a legit video editor who might want to
work with the team
info drastic graphics.com there we go
info drasticgraphics.com
and also have a sense of humor
you really got to be like i when i was
onboarding deanna
i realized how like i knew i worked with
comics but with you it's different
and i'm just so glad she was cool
because i was like not everybody would
be cool with what we do
and it's outlandish to the average
person
i'm just so glad i know how to scale it
because like when i met deanna i'm
i like no be be a normal person at a
restaurant
yeah you're great that's why that's why
you're so great because you can
you can just anybody personally they
don't like that let's talk like this
it's not like you're changing the way
you are you're just using different
words so you don't go [ __ ]
62 times well yeah somebody but when
you're dealing with like a you know a 23
year old girl who might be kind of like
you know
reserved or maybe a little bit shy like
you're not going to talk
obviously that's knowing your audience
yeah exactly we're not going to be crazy
talking about [ __ ] drug stories and
[ __ ] around there but the point is you
got to be [ __ ] cool
yeah you have to be a nice person and by
cool we don't mean like oh you're the
[ __ ] like who wasn't like
you're not a piece of [ __ ] and you work
hard that's cool that that was actually
a really horrible description on my
apartment
no but cool to us as well you work hard
and you're nice yeah you're dedicated
and we can trust you that's all we need
you're reliable
yeah that's all we need we i can teach
skills there's [ __ ] i can't teach that
falls under
dedication and reliability but also know
how to do video editing
yeah and now not rush or imovie like me
do real [ __ ] final cut of premiere
pro because we need people that can chop
throw [ __ ] transitions do this and
that anyway info jurassic graphics.com
all right please do not just
email if you're not qualified man i mean
there's nothing worse than that will
slow the process it's just gonna yeah
it's just gonna slow us down
i i love you guys but we also need
people that know how to do the job like
if i'm a hiring construction worker i'm
like yeah i'm a
really really good cook like bro [ __ ]
yeah okay all right well if i'm hiring a
cook one day
it's important to note though that i
didn't put this out like i usually do i
only put it out on my instagram because
i only want dope as usual fantastic
unless i don't find anybody but i'm
pretty sure that i'm going to that's a
big thing though because if you're
watching you're applying and you're
qualified you really like the show
that's the point you want to be a part
of it sick
that's great yeah i could have reached
out to a bunch of colleges and gone
through like how i found diana on
linkedin but it's like i want somebody
who
likes listening to the episodes and
already understands our vision and our
tone that i would much rather give back
to our fan base like that
it's [ __ ] awesome if i liked the show
and i was able to do some [ __ ] with it
oh please
come on [ __ ] out of here i'll be hyped
as hell
all i'm looking for is a lesser version
of myself [ __ ]
10 years ago we just wanted that if we
had three of you man
we oh my [ __ ] god guys
marty edits all the dobasiola videos the
dope as usual videos
the adventures of yolo videos and then
works with the hell
all the other comedians there's not
enough time in the day
so that's why the videos have been
sporadically like oh maybe we missed a
couple days
because it's real i can only do so much
editing and pass it off
so we need three of our three marty's if
we have three marties we have three
videos a week
all right dope as usual adventures
double joel video three a week
we're getting there we're getting there
we're getting there we just need
to clone your ass it's all part of the
process this this is how we planned it
out when we first
before we even started i said i'm gonna
grow drastic graphics through this yes
to help support it and help make it just
even bigger and more sustainable and
that's exactly what we're doing
yeah so infographicgraphics.com guys
um we are almost at two hours and we
[ __ ] i don't know where the time went
i don't remember what i'm i this is weed
this weed is strong
all right it's good conversation too
yeah i just spaced
for like an hour yeah we talked about i
feel like that's every episode though i
know
i know and then i always go yo did i
just not talk
like no it's fine then we watch you go
i'm [ __ ] high yeah i know i'm like
every time i hope it was good i hope it
was a good one because i feel like i
wasn't talking a lot
wait no you were a [ __ ] you just
you're high i'm gonna scale it back a
little bit maybe drink a little more
water
um i'm gonna give you guys one story
before we leave though and i will
tighten that [ __ ] up to six minutes
before it's two before it's two hours
i'm gonna be done with the story all
right here's a challenge video this is
an unofficial [ __ ] yeah thank you
with the hand
god damn it all right
what i'm just oh oh
oh yeah oh yeah i'm on it i'm uh
i think i think of all that [ __ ]
we got deals going guys let's yeah we
can't be showing out these water
companies
and we're over here doing deals with
other water companies
hey man we all drink water exactly all
right here we go
okay guys i'm gonna give you one story
before we leave i'm gonna try to keep
this
precise i'm not gonna go off into
[ __ ] tangents of my favorite kid
shows and [ __ ] when i was a kid because
it'll happen all right here we go this
story takes place
when i was working for the pizza place
if you don't know a little backstory i
used to deliver pizza
and sell weed at the same time and it
was the best cover ever had
because nobody pulls over the pizza guy
so excuse me
here we go i used to sell weed to my
boss's mom
my boss smokes weed with us he's cool
you know he doesn't know i sell wheat on
my routes
but he knows i smoke weed knows i sell
weed out of my house he probably assumed
but he never
he he can't catch me doing it there's no
way you know what i'm saying
so we're cool we have an understanding i
smoke weed i sell weed but not at work
anyway he says i can smoke weed just
don't come in wreaking and don't have
any customers complain about it and i
never had a complaint
so here we go my boss is cool with me
i'm doing deliveries i'm coming back in
as i walk back into the store my boss is
getting off and as he's getting off work
we always know he's off work
he's at the bar drinking beer he calls
his wife to pick him up because he knows
he's gonna drink after work
he'll take like two or three beers go
home at the end of his work day nothing
[ __ ] wrong
that's that's the cool little system
he's got right as he waits for his wife
he drinks some beers
so there's a guy that comes in with his
family all the time you know we have
regulars i
do everything i chili drive i make
pizzas i take orders i take pizzas out
to people in the restaurant
i'm team player so here we go i know
this guy i don't know him by name but i
know his family i recognize him right
so when i walk back in that day my boss
like i said he's drinking a beer
and that guy is with him i just know
that guy always has his wife and kids
with him
but on this day it's just him and he's
having a beer with my boss
getting my pizzas ready doing my thing
i'm about to leave on delivery
as i'm walking around the soda machine
where the bar is at he stops me and goes
hey thomas come here
so i come around the counter and he's
with the guy the guy has like a manila
envelope
with the little you know those little
metal tabs that you have to open up so
it keeps the papers down
he has one of those so my boss looks at
me and says hey
do you want to make 30 bucks on your
next delivery and stupid question
a [ __ ] yeah i mean like five dollar tips
you know i want to make 30 [ __ ]
dollars on this delivery that's like
selling a [ __ ] zip right now
yes let's do it so i tell him let's do
it
and he says okay the guy starts talking
to me
and he says hey i'm gonna give you this
30 bucks i go sick give me the 30 bucks
just drop off this envelope to my wife
and i go cool
sick that's it and john looks at me goes
that's it
oh cool he gives me my 30 bucks sick and
it's not even far from my delivery it
was like two miles away from my delivery
so it's only gonna take me like an extra
eight minutes to get there
[ __ ] awesome that would have took me
30 bucks and tips took me five six
deliveries so
i'm hyped right i'm going there i drop
off my pizza
i'm like [ __ ] yeah i'm smoking a bowl
because that's what i did in my car
i'm smoking a bowl i get to ward i think
it was wardrobe street it's by the pepsi
plant if you're from merced it's by the
pepsi factory
right off second street dead end park
where all the gangbangers are at it's
right there
there's like a government building not
by a valley valley's like the really bad
school for kids
i mean the really the school for really
bad kids when you get kicked out of the
continuation school you go to valley
anyway at valley there's like uh
offices like um maybe like city offices
not like
i don't know what you call it ladies
that work for the city anyway
i go up to the building i don't have my
pizza bag but i have my whole outfit i
have my hat you know my shirt my name
tag
i walk in with them with the envelope
and i and right when i walk in the lady
in the front oh who ordered pizza she's
like you know that
generic office worker lady oh she i go
oh um
nobody ordered but i'm supposed to meet
and i say the name and she goes
oh she turns around and says the lady's
name the lady turns around in her chair
comes walking over so i didn't order any
pizza i go oh no no it's not an order
um your husband came in to mean ed's and
she goes uh i'm like
he came into me in ed and he asked me to
give this envelope i don't know he said
on your next delivery he dropped this
off to my wife at work
he told me to ask for you and then give
you the envelope she goes oh okay
nothing wrong she goes okay but she kind
of has like a
huh okay takes the envelope
i turn my ass around start walking out i
get if there was 15 feet from the door
and the front receptionist desk i get
seven feet so i'm like almost halfway
there i and i hear
what the [ __ ] i turn around
she's looking at some paper that's in
she has the manila envelope still
opens it reading a paper and she just
looks up at me
so i stop i hear what the [ __ ] i look at
her
and her eyes are down then just death
stare
i'm like what the [ __ ] all right
i don't give a [ __ ] i turn my back i
turn my ass around again
start walking to the door remember i
said about 15 feet the second
i get to the door a couple feet before
that i can hear the other ladies like oh
my god i can hear them all talking like
her co-workers
right when i put my hand on the door i
realize what's going on like and if you
didn't catch this yet
you're like me you're slow i didn't know
what i was doing i thought i was just
dropping off some papers to this guy's
wife
as i get there and i'm like assessing
what the [ __ ]
death stare oh my god
as i put my hand on the door i go i just
serve that woman divorce papers
i know what i just did i finally
realized it's like a movie like uh
yeah there's in the usual suspects it
goes back guatemalan beans oh yeah
and it goes back to all these clues
that's what's playing in my head like
30 bucks make sure you ask her her name
blah blah at her work
oh [ __ ] and i get outside and i go no
i go to my car get back in my car i
smoke a bowl in the [ __ ] parking lot
because i'm like nah
i'm taking my time you guys [ __ ]
played you could've just said you're
serving divorce papers can you drop to
my wife
i would have been fine don't let me find
out when the [ __ ] starts looking at me
all
all crazy right like she put me in a
[ __ ] position
i get back to work i pull up i walk in
i walk in and my boss and that guy have
a mug of beer and they're looking at me
like this
like about to drink it i walk in my bag
and go
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you i look at both of them
and they both just
start dying laughing i wasn't pissed but
i'm like
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you like i was smiling
like you guys are dick and i'm like
[ __ ] you guys you should have told me
the guy looks at me he's like
i [ __ ] hate her and the thing is she
did not seem very nice
so i'm like as i'm driving away like she
was kind of a dick why are you looking
at me like that [ __ ] [ __ ] you i'm
i'm literally a messenger in
my delivery suit right like why are you
gonna get mad at me
i literally said i was at just at work
and they asked me to bring it
oh i had no idea and he's like i [ __ ]
hate her so much
and i look at my balls and like yo she
was kind of a dick
and then he started dying live he's like
see see
this is why i'm getting a divorce i'm
like oh man and then i went
throughout my day but that's the time i
served a [ __ ] woman divorce papers
high as [ __ ] when i thought i was just
dropping off some stuff to some guy's
wife on a delivery
so that's my story how long is that like
eight minutes
yeah yeah that was pretty good dude i
kept
pretty pretty precise i didn't [ __ ] up
and talk about the first time i you know
got a tooth knocked
yeah there you go all right here we go
nice
um but yeah that was it guys that was
the time i
served those papers and we were at what
two hours and two minutes
all right here we go guys thank you so
much for watching i'm gonna i'm gonna
seal this one up
tomorrow i know this is before marty
leaves but marty's leaving to hawaii
in a couple days ten year anniversary
correct ten year marriage
ten year marriage anniversary oh [ __ ]
going to hawaii
it's important to know all the kids out
there we were too broke to have a
honeymoon when we got married so we said
by our 10th year anniversary we want to
go to [ __ ] hawaii and when's your
actual anniversary
like oh june 5th oh so you'll be there
already
yes so like we're doing the whole like
vowel renewals and all that it would be
cool to have my kids
like the kids that weren't there for the
first one yeah
that'd be awesome yeah nice dude so
you're gonna be gone for a week
yep yep so marty's leaving soon that
means i'm gonna be filming
and i might have a day off this week
because i am filming a podcast we're
doing it early
holy [ __ ] i got a day off what am i
going to do you don't know
answer comments what you need to do is
make a
schedule yeah like we talk about yeah
i have it just it's not feasible it's
not feasible it's not yeah
you guys are gonna notice after about i
feel like maybe once we hit a round
episode like 25
30 like we're gonna be in a [ __ ]
really nice groove
between all your channels yeah we just
need
more help we
physically can't do it all right that's
all it is editing okay
if we didn't care as much about
production and quality and look
we can pump these out [ __ ] put it out
the same day on camera
done we could be done i could be just
sitting here [ __ ]
peter griffin grab my gear [ __ ] all day
but it's not it's fun
we want that intro and outro and [ __ ]
yeah this is real authentic
i like that the fans recognize that
people are happy with it especially when
the 4k
part of it yeah and then there's
suggestions oh maybe it pops up next
week
i mean we do read the comments like i
[ __ ] answer every
[ __ ] comment up to a thousand
legitimately and then i'm done
after a thousand that's like look at a
thousand comments
so much try to like a thousand comments
and it's not like i'm doing copy paste
either no you're legitimately sitting
there typing on
answers to each one you've developed eye
issues over it yeah i
i'm gonna have to stop soon i'm gonna
i'm gonna have to i'm gonna
end up doing up to 300 comments or
something because i have four channels
that i do the comments for it's [ __ ] a
lot
and i try to answer them all to a
thousand but that's like [ __ ] 12
hours a week
that's a lot it's i do it in between
editing or when i'm laying there when
the movie's starting and when you're as
you're watching i'll do it until the
[ __ ] people start talking
i'm done sorry yeah i feel bad like i
don't want to just be on my [ __ ]
phone while we're watching the movie
yeah i feel bad
but also i work all day every day until
i fall asleep
when i fall at four or five in the
morning every time you
time like oh my god what time is it
marty's facetiming me
i went to bed at six [ __ ] i just wish i
could fall asleep on time man and i have
to go to [ __ ] birthday party after
this so i am not going to bed
anytime soon times oh god
damn damn okay yeah my friend are you
coming this is his birthday i feel bad
um so guys marty's going to hawaii i
might have a day off this week
you should not be working while you're
gone i know you're like bringing my
computer and everything like
yeah i'm going to try to keep that yeah
don't try not to
yeah um guys thank you for being here
this is just this is just an episode of
us talking man
i didn't really like have any any crazy
things i wanted to do i wanted to keep
it
not so many wild long stories just
for this is just the car podcast this is
always fun like it's
when you're booking guests and stuff
it's always kind of like you don't know
what style interview you're going to get
or if they're going to show up or
whatever but like it's
even in my mind coming up here it might
not even seem like it it takes
like to even just get set up and get
up and run over to this big [ __ ]
ordeal so the solo episodes are just
like
like we're talking it is the vibes that
we were going for like you just
especially you just get to chill back
and just like ah all right
the fun part is the actual recording of
the episode yeah everything is relaxed
yes exactly um
oh my god man i really really really
need to i just need to start and take
some pills to help you
i have a great memory but i will forget
a topic i'm about to say
in four seconds flat why don't i don't
know 8k
style photography memory it's kind of
[ __ ] insane
how it works that way but i can't
remember some [ __ ] i was about to say
five seconds ago sometimes
i got regular stoner [ __ ] mm-hmm people
are like holy [ __ ] do you forget what
you said i did
but i remember what it tastes like when
i first time i ate ruffles when i was in
the hospital
i think i'm not all that so sick um
but yes uh we'll get we'll get out of
here guys oh that's what's gonna say
we have some guests lined up we're
working on some other guests right now
we have one guest booked i'm [ __ ]
hyped all right i think it'll be
the one after this or the one two after
this we have
one really [ __ ] awesome funny ass
comedian booked
um you guys already know um goblin the
youtuber you guys want you've been
asking us to do it for so long so
that's happening another one i'm waiting
on right now but they can only do skype
so we're
gonna pass until they can come in person
because we do not do skype [ __ ]
podcasts
no matter how legendary no [ __ ] no it's
not the same it's not going to be the
same vibe
yeah of course i would i'd rather just
no
and then we have one more we're waiting
on i think that one's going to happen
i think the one you know which one time
i i think it's going to happen
and i can't wait i can't wait because my
first my right i won't give it away but
my first opening line in the interview
for this person is
how does it feel to know you're the
scariest mexican man
to ever live the scariest guy
ever damn
that's a big thing it's a big deal of
all mexican people like people thank you
first when they think of scary mexican
dudes
yeah definitely youthful that's who i
think
oh yeah and i want to give it away but
that's all i'll give you
um i'm already have fun on your vacation
be safe sir um guys we're gonna hop out
here
thank you so much for watching this has
been another episode thank you guys so
much for hanging out with us
sitting if you're driving please be safe
if you're at home thanks for hanging out
if you're with your friends
thanks for letting us join the [ __ ]
70s show smoke circle
thank you guys for being here if you're
on spotify if you're on apple
leave a review it really [ __ ] helps
please leave a review but if you're
being a [ __ ] don't leave a review
but nobody's getting back yeah i know we
have almost a thousand
five star [ __ ] ratings just
organically
it's amazing holy [ __ ] [ __ ] that's a
lot of time for you guys to take out of
your day to do that so thank you that
helps so much and right now is the times
like we're in this like
point right now of like shouting at
these [ __ ] companies and
yes so we're closing on some legendary
ass [ __ ]
we're trying to get it done and when it
comes i'm not saying if
when it comes gotta pour it on you guys
are gonna trip balls
you guys are gonna [ __ ] lose you got
who to sponsor your podcast
what the [ __ ] do you just say like i
know nfl
i'm just kidding it's not the nfl it was
nfl like nah i need troy aikman to be my
[ __ ] co-host
how random that would be all right guys
this sunday right now
make sure you don't miss out your game
passes [ __ ]
vegas las vegas raiders fourth fret for
our [ __ ] brett favre
oh man one day brett favre one day brett
favre
you're gonna meet me in person and i'm
gonna go hey i know you don't remember
oh thomas right san francisco yeah i
don't [ __ ] like him like
no he's gonna actually does remember
yeah he's like i'm that one that that's
the unlike on every premiere that's
[ __ ] breathtaking yo real quick why
the [ __ ] is joe biden's kid follow us
that's a great question it's all over
shout out to whoever dm yeah
i even see it on twitter like yeah you
know joe biden's grandson
follows you like so random
sick nice funny can we get verified can
he pull some goddamn
[ __ ] string just can a [ __ ]
get monetized for real
dude god hey i heard you know some
people
with authority i heard
you were born into a door he might be
able to pull a few strings
give me a [ __ ] blue check
um sorry we'll we'll leave we'll leave
it off with that
guys thank you so much for watching um
this has been another episode of dope as
usual podcast
like i said in no particular order we're
talking about drugs problems life
accomplishments
and everything in between and today was
a lot of everything in between fun
[ __ ] times
marty be safe on your trip guys thank
you so much for watching
have a dope ass day
yo what the [ __ ] why does he that's so
random
you think they'd be like nah man you're
the president's grandson
you cannot openly follow this [ __ ]
pothead kid
i [ __ ] love i think it's funny though
yo dude
when rihanna started following my [ __ ]
people
literally lost their [ __ ] minds and
were emailing me dude brianna [ __ ] with
my wheat [ __ ] heavy
but i keep getting deleted so it's not
like i'm gonna go hey rihanna follow me
again
[Laughter]
cause i don't know that girl she's
famous as [ __ ]
[Music]
perfect perfect
[Music]
perfect
[Music]